COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER N
RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
CAPITAL ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
WITH NONE OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
BEDROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE WITH
ME WILL BE SENATORS CORTESE
DOLLY GLAZER MCGUIRE MITCHELL
THOUGH. AND PAN. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. NINE
SIX TWO FIVE ZERO THREE FIVE.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE FOUR ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE AS THIS CAN
BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU'RE NOT
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON A PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING. SERVICE OR
HAVE THE CONNECTIONS MUTED
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT FOR
HEARINGS AND IS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME WAIT TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS FOR JUSTIN TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT FOR ALL.
INTERESTED BILL PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE EIGHT BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THREE OF THOSE
BILLS ARE ON CONSENT. THE BILLS
ON CONSENT BAR. ITEM TWO SB TWO
TWO NINE. SEVEN FOUR SB FIVE TO
FIVE. ITEM FIVE SB SIX ONE SIX.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION ON
THESE BILLS WHAT THE STAFF
PERSON QUORUM. MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. LEYVA
HERE FAVORITE HERE PHOTO ABOVE
HERE THE TROUBLE CARE CORTESE
REFER TO THE HERE TALLY HERE
ALLEN HERE GLAZER. GLAZER HERE
MCGUIRE PAN AM HERE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM MEN CONSULTANT LET'S
TAKE UP OF THE- CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE A MOTION.
THANK YOU THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZERS MEDIC CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND SENT LEYVA
BYE BYE BYE PHOTO ABODE I
FLETCHER BOGUE COURTESY. I
COURTESY AYE TELLING AYE DELHI
AYE GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN HI CAN I THINK YOU
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
SENATOR MCGUIRE TO VOTE MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM OUR
FIRST AUTHOR WHOSE SENATOR
DOLLY A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE SENATOR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT FROM YOUR SEAT.
PERFECT PLEASE START WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FIRST I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
STAFF ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
GET MY SB TWO TWO NINE ON.
CONSENT I APPRECIATE THAT.
SINCE A LOT SINCE I LAST
PRESENTED S. B. TWO SEVENTEEN
OF A MINUTE OUT LANGUAGE THAT
REQUIRED TO EDUCATION MATERIALS
BE TRANSLATED. NOW SB TWO
SEVENTY SIMPLY REQUIRES A
SEXUAL EDUCATION MATERIALS TO
BE POSTED ONLINE FOR PARENTS TO
BE ABLE TO REVIEW THEM. GIVEN
THE CURRENT DISTANCE LEARNING
EDUCATION SYSTEM EVEN IF IT
RECENT PLAN FORCE. FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
OPEN. OFTENTIMES CANNOT
PHYSICALLY VISIT THE SCHOOL TO
ACQUIRE MATERIALS THAT WOULD BE
TAUGHT TO THEIR CHILDREN'S.
SECTION FIVE ONE THREE NINE
EIGHT B. ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA
OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY YOUTH
ACT REQUIRES THAT PARENTS BE
NOTIFIED THAT THE MATERIAL IS
AVAILABLE FOR INSPECTION.
SCHOOLS MAY BE LEGALLY EXPOSED
IF THEY DO NOT PROVIDE THE
MATERIALS FOR PARENT PARENTAL
REVIEW. AND LIMITING IN PERSON
INSPECTION DURING DISTANCE
LEARNING LEAVES. THE INTERNET
AS THE ONLY OPTION FOR
COMPLIANCE. THE SHIFT TO THE
INTERNET BASED DISTANCE
LEARNING HAS PROVIDED AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR SCHOOLS TO GET
PARENTS MORE ENGAGED IN THEIR
CHILD'S EDUCATION AND THIS BILL
HELPS FOR THAT GOAL. WE ALL ALL
WE ARE DOING HERE IS TO ENSURE
THAT PARENTS CAN BE ENGAGED AT.
THE LEVEL THEY CHOOSE IN THEIR
CHILD'S EDUCATION WITH ME TODAY
I HAVE. TO TESTIFY IS KIM
NICHOLS A MOTHER OF A SCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN AND REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONCERT CONFERENCE. AND JOB
WELL BECAUSE OF THE COCKLE
GROUP THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY
WILL NW GO TO LEAD SUPPORT. MR
BALKO IF YOU WERE ON THE LINE
PLEASE PROCEED AND THEN WE WILL
GO TO MS NICHOLS. EACH OF YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES I AM BAD
MEMBERS JACK WALKER- THE GLOCK
AGREED POINTING OUT THAT.
THROUGH JESUS CHRIST OF LATTER
DAY SAINTS. AND THE CHURCH'S
BELIEVE BELIEVE THAT PARENTS
PLAYING A- ROLE IN THE- OF
CHILDREN. AND PARENTS NURTURED
TWENTY ANOTHER WOULD BEING
TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS REGARDING SEX
EDUCATION. SO THAT THEY CAN
SUPPLEMENT AND- SUPPORT LEARN.
THE TURKISH PUBLIC. ON FEB
EDUCATION OF THAT QUOTE PARENTS
SHOULD HAVE ON A CLEAR AND
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEIR CHILDREN ABOUT HEALTHY.
BREAKFAST SEXUALITY. BUT PART
OF THE RESPONSIBILITY TO TEACH
THEIR CHILDREN. PARENTS SHOULD
BE AWARE OF INAPPROPRIATELY.
INFLUENCE DEFECT EDUCATION AT
SCHOOL END OF QUOTE. A COUPLE
YEARS AGO MADAM CHAIR CHURCH
TRY TO DETERMINE WHICH DETECT
EDUCATION CURRICULUM WAS BEING
USED WHAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS. IN
CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY MOST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FAILED OR
REFUSED BY THE COMMISSION OF
PARENTS. AND PARENTS REQUESTED
IT EVEN WHEN THE PARENTS SHOWED
UP IN PERSON. THE DISTRICT
OFFICE. THE MAIN CONCERN FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WOULD
MANDATE SUCH CONSTRUCTION AND
PROVIDE AN OPT OUT OPPORTUNITY.
BUT NOT MANDATED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS PROVIDE INFORMATION
TO PARENTS IN ORDER TO ALLOW
THEM TO MAKE THAT DECISION. WE
CURRENTLY UNFAVORABLE POSITION
OF MAKING THAT DECISION. AND
AVOID. PRINT ALL OF ALL THAT IS
WHY WE PROVIDING INPUT AND
HELPING SCHOOL DISTRICTS. IN
ORDER TO GET INVOLVED IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY PARENTS NEED TO
TRANSPARENCY THAT SENATOR DOLLY
SB TWO SEVENTEEN WILL REQUIRE
ESPECIALLY THE ONLINE AUCTION
FOR WORKING PARENTS IN THOSE
OTHERWISE UNABLE TO GET TO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT DURING BUSINESS
HOURS. OTHER STATES REQUIRE
THIS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE LEADING
NOT LAGGING OF THE ISSUE. HELLO
WE BETTER. WE ARE RESPECT
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE I
HONESTLY TWO ONE THREE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SIR
NEXT UP IS MS NICHOLS PLEASE
PROCEED. HI GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KEN NICHOLS AND I THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR. SB TWO SEVENTEEN I
AM AT THE PARENT OF Q.
ELEMENTARY AGE CHILDREN WHO
ATTEND PUBLIC SCHOOL IN THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA AND I'M
THANKFUL TO SENATOR DOLLY FOR
RECOGNIZE THE THAT THE PARENTS
WOULD LIKE TO ACCESS. UNISEXUAL
I DID HEALTH EDUCATION
MATERIALS TALK TO THEIR
CHILDREN AND MAKE ESSENTIALLY
OUR BUSY LIVES A LITTLE EASIER.
AND SO MANY FAMILIES OF THE
LAST YEAR HAVE EXPERIENCE AND
MY KIDS AND I WEREN'T COOL
DISTANCE LEARNING MODE AND TELL
A FEW SHORT WEEKS AGO. AND
DISTANCE LEARNING WAS
ESPECIALLY CHALLENGING IN THE
BEGINNING BECAUSE COMMON CURIAL
AND BOOKS WERE NOT ALLOWED
HOME. INITIALLY AND I FOUND
MYSELF FRANTICALLY GOOGLING
MATH QUESTIONS ARE. TRYING TO
LEARN THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
TEACH MY SON HOW TO WRITE A
PARAGRAPH AND THEN THERE IS
OFTEN A LOT OF TENSION. BETWEEN
WHAT ITHOUGHT UNLESS AND UNTIL
THEN MAYBE WHAT MY SON
UNDERSTOOD HIS TEACHER'S
INTENTION. TO BE- WHAT'S THAT
THE THINGS WERE IRONED OUT
MATERIALS WERE PROVIDED FOR
HOME USE DISTANCE LEARNING WAS
MUCH YOU KNOW THEY'RENOT ABLE
TO WITH THAT AND IF THE ANSWER
QUESTIONS. WHEN NEEDED AND IN
THE SAME VEIN I'M SUPPORTING AT
THE TWO SEVENTEEN BECAUSE IT
WILL AFFORD ME THAT SAME
OPPORTUNITY. TO REVIEW SEXUAL
EDUCATION AND HEALTH MATERIALS
PRESENTED TO MY CHILDREN.
ONLINE IN A CONVENIENT MANNER
AND THEN PARTNER WITH THE
SCHOOL TO EXTEND THAT EDUCATION
AT HOME. AND THAT THIS WOULD
ALLOW ME TO PREPARE TO CONTINUE
TO BUILD ON THE INFORMATION IN
THE CLASSROOM. AND EXTEND THAT
AND SHOULD THE NEED ARISE
SHOULD MY CHILDREN HAVE
QUESTIONS OR POSSIBLY EVEN HAVE
CONFUSION ABOUT INFORMATION
THAT WAS PRESENTED IN WHAT
CLARIFICATION. HAVING OF
MATERIALS READILY AVAILABLE
ONLINE THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
REVISIT THEM AT HOME AND IF
NEEDED- AND OF THE WORKING
PARENT IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
THE ABILITY.TO HAVE THAT
CONVENIENCE OF HAVING THEM
ACCESSIBLE. ONLINE- AND
OBVIOUSLY HEALTH AT AS A-
IMPORTANT AND- IT IMPACTS
MICHAEL HEALTH AN EX. THANK
RIGHT AWAY CAN WRAP UP CLEAR
PASSWORD TWO MINUTES IN EUROPE
UP PLEASE. YES I JUST ENCOURAGE
ALL TO SB TWO SOME AND ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER MY CHILD
TEACHERS TO CONTINUE TO EXPAND.
THEIR LEARNING IN THE CLASSROOM
AND OUR HOME ENVIRONMENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NOW WE WILL GO
FOR A SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. PLEASE COME
UP TO THE MICROPHONE AND STATE
YOUR NAME. AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL. RESERVE WHAT-
GREG BURKE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR DINI'S PERSIA CITIZEN
AUTHOR AND- OF SIX SEVEN THREE
AND IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO ONE
SEVEN. YOU SEE NO ONE ELSE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE LET'S GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NO
ONE THERE- MODERATOR LET'S OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO'S
CALLING AND TELEPHONICALLY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN FOR SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AB ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. YEAH. OUR FIRST ARTISTS
WILL BE LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD FIFTY SIX. FIFTY SIX
COMMUTERS. MOVING ALONG WITH
ONLINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM SURE CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN HEAR YOU JUST FINE AS
THE MODERATOR OKAY I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE BECAUSE
PARTICIPANTS ARE NOT
RESPONDING. NINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MOVE
ALONG TO WIND THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH ANY
HEARING FROM THAT THE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB TWO SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU I
WON TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PROBABLY THAT PERSON FROM ACT
MONTEREY BAY STRONG SUPPORT HE
SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
MOVE ON TO LINE TWENTY SIX YOU
ARE OPEN. KALENJIN CASKEY-
MONTEREY COUNTY CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO ONE
SEVEN THANK YOU. ONE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU
FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO ONE
SEVEN KALRA PAN AND
TRANSPARENCY TO LEARN ABOUT THE
EXTENT. THANK YOU ONE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RANDY
LINDQUIST OF SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA AND IN STRONG VITAL
SUPPORT SB TWO ONE SEVEN PLEASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I COR IN
A KENNEL WITH ADVOCATE FOR
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN IN BRAZIL
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORTER
AND SB TWO SEVENTY. ONE FORTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS LISA DID BROWN ON A
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER FROM WEST
COUNTRY CLUB THE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FIND TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS BRIAN BOTH
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA- FATHER
JUST EXTREMELY SUPPORT OF SB
TWO ONE SEVEN THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS RICHARD MILLER I'M
A FATHER AND PASTOR VICTORY
BAPTIST CHURCH NOT WHILE THE
CALIFORNIA IN A STRONG SUPPORT
SB TWO ONE. THIRTY ONE YOUR UP.
OKAY HI I AM HAVE THEIR GIPSON
I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
AND I'M A MOTHER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB TWO SEVENTEEN. WE
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR LINE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
GRATEFUL CRUTCHFIELD AND STRONG
SUPPORT AS AN EACH YEAR BY
SEVEN THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
I'M LEAH TO THROUGH A PARENT OF
FIVE KIDS IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS
RIGHT NOW FROM KINDERGARTEN ALL
AND I AM SHOCKED IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVENTEEN.
PINE THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE MILLER
FROM ATWATER CALIFORNIA AND I
AM IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. FIND FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS NEW
YOU KNOW I AM A GRANDMOTHER OF
THE TWO KIDS I STRONGLY SUPPORT
S. B. TWO ONE SEVEN THANK YOU.
FIND FORTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. I
AM PART CHAMBERS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT- TWO ONE SEVEN. MOVING
ALONG WE WILL GO TO LINE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN
CALIFORNIA AND I JUST.
BEEKEEPER THANK YOU OUR LINE
SEVEN PLEASE GOING. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. NINE
NINE SEVENTEEN YES YOU ARE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU AND
APART FROM SHOULD USE YOUR
DIGITAL BANKING SO NEXT YEAR.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN.
THANK YOU LINE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS CARRIE
MOTT LEAD FROM WRAPPING
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB TWO SEVENTEEN. TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. HI THIS IS
JULIE HOLYOKE FROM ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF TWO SEVENTEEN THANK YOU.
TWENTY FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY WILLIAM SAULS WITH L.
ATTORNEY AND- THOUSAND OAKS
CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS THIS
BILL IS NECESSARY TO MAKE THE
CURRICULUM REGIME
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECT CURRENT
ALSO ARRIVES. THANK YOU LINE
SIXTY TWO YOUR OPEN. YES HELLO
MY NAME IS MICHELLE GONZALEZ
NIL I AM HERE SAYING I SUPPORT
S. B. TWO ONE SEVEN. I AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR S.
B. TWO ONE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME AND WE WILL GO TO LINE.
SIXTY FIVE. THE GLOBAL WARMING
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE'S STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AISLEYNE SIXTY SIX
YOU ARE OPEN. HI TONY ARAMBULA
FROM CAPITOL RESOURCE INSTITUTE
IN THE CHORUS SB. TWO
SEVENTEEN. LINE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHOULD TRY
MARLO TUCKER CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR OF CONCERNED WOMEN FOR
AMERICA WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL. LINE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
OKAY. MICHAEL MCCABE FROM
TRADITIONAL I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO ONE SEVEN.
LINE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOD MORNING CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES YES- MY NAME IS
WENDY LEE AND I AM LIVING COSTA
MESA CALIFORNIA I AM STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT IT SB TWO SEVENTEEN
I AM CURRENTLY A CREDENTIALED
TEACHER- GRANDMOTHER AND MOTHER
OF FIVE AND FORMER TRUSTEE FOR
THE NEWPORT MESA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I'M I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT BECAUSE DARING COMMANDO
YOUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
EIGHTEEN. PINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS A
JUNKIE FEDERAL I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SB THREE ONE SEVEN.
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE A EXHAUSTED
THE QUEUE EXCELLENT THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR WE WILL NOW GO
INTO OPPOSITION I THINK OUR
LEAD OPPOSITION IS JENNIFER
CHANNEL JENNIFER ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. HEY AS EARLY AND I'M HERE
PLEASE PROCEDURE OF TIME WITH.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS JENNIFER
CHINA I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH THE
ACLU OF BURNING CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF EIGHT BILLION
CALIFORNIA ACTION. I'M GOOD AT
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY YOUTH
ACTOR CHAYEI WHICH THIS BILL
SEEKS TO AMEND. THE OPPOSE ANTI
TO SEVENTEEN PER NUMBER OF
REASONS. I ALREADY ADDRESSED
THE TRANSPARENCY PERFECT TO ADD
AND SUBTRACT THE BALANCE BUT
ALSO ENSURE SUFFICIENT
FLEXIBILITY FOR DETECTING NEED
THE NEEDS AND THEIR INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITY. CHILD ALREADY
REQUIRES PARENT AND GUARDIAN
NOTIFICATIONS ABOUT THE RIGHT
TERM VIEW CURRICULUM WHICH
DESTRUCTIVE THOUGHT TATE IN A
VARIETY OF WAYS DEPENDING ON
THEIR CAPACITY AND THEIR
STRUCTURE AN EXISTING CHANNEL
FOR COMMUNICATING WITH PARENTS
INCLUDING. PRETTY NICE
INDIVIDUAL APPOINTMENT AND IN
THE RARE AND THANK NOT
PROHIBITED BY COPYRIGHT POSTING
MATERIALS ONLINE. PROCESS
CONTENT PROPHECIES CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN EVEN OVER A DISTANCE
LEARNING AFTER NEW PARENTS AND
GUARDIANS AND HAVE THE RIGHT TO
OPT. OUT OF. INSTRUCTION IF
THEY STILL WISH. I NOT BEING.
THAT THE DOES LEVEL THAT A-
LEVEL. I CAN'T THE BILL AND
DOES THE WAY ANTI WITH THE-
REQUIREMENTS FOR TRANS NOTED
FROM AND GUARDIANS. THESE ARE
CRITICAL BASELINE PROTECTIONS
FOR FAMILIES WHO DO NOT SPEAK
ENGLISH AS A FIRST LANGUAGE AT
HOME. THE TWO SEVENTEEN AND
UNDER THE BURNS AND REQUIREMENT
ON TAX AT THAT DOESN'T EXIST
FOR OTHER TOPICS. WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THE PAST LIFE OF THIS
BILL GROUP STARTING DANGEROUS
AND FALSE ANTI LGBTQ PLUS
MESSAGING. ARE SINGLING OUT
THINK THAT TO BE MORE DIFFICULT
TO IMPLEMENT AND OTHER
INSTRUCTION AND HER OUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CHINA THE
PRIMARY OBJECTION. HAS RARELY
BEEN TO THE PROCESS OF
DELIVERING FACT ADD. TO THE
FACT THAT CHINA MANDATED
INSTRUCTION MUST BE INCLUSIVE
MEDICALLY CCURATE AND
OBJECTIVE. BY REQUIRING ALL
DISTRICT TO GO BACK TO THE
DRAWING BOARD ON TEXT AND THIS
BILL WOULD DERAIL AFFECTIVE AND
HEALTH EDUCATION. AT A TIME
WHEN YOU THINK HEALTH EDUCATION
THEM OUT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE NO LEADER
OPPOSITE WILL TO OFFICE HERE IN
FORTY OF. SEEING THAT LET'S GO
TO TWENTY FORTY SEEING NONE.
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AND AGAIN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR S. B. TWO TWO
ONE SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH WINE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ANDREA SAN MIGUEL FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIA CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE SEVEN AFFILIATE THE WORK
WITH SCHOOLS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS TO
IMPLEMENT CHILD. CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. ONE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU ONE SIXTY ONE. YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CARLOS MACHADO
WITH A CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION- WE ARE OPPOSED TO
SDG SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT AGAIN I WILL
GIVE ANOTHER REMINDER TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO BILL S. B. TWO
ONE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AN LINE FORTY
SIX YOU ARE OPEN. I'M KAREN
MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN EVAN
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TWENTY FIFTY THANK
YOU USING MADAM CHAIR AND LINE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STRYCHNINE IN OPPOSITION. AND
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR WE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS. FENDER GLAZER AN
INCENTIVE CORTESE. THANK YOU I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR NOT
NOT GIVING UP ON A BILL AND
TRYING TO FIND COMMON GROUND I
APPRECIATE THAT- I DIDN'T
SUPPORT THE MEASURE PREVIOUSLY
YOU KNOW THE ISSUE OF LOCAL
CONTROL IS A VERY BIG DEAL TO
ME- BUT- I GUESS I'D LIKE TO
ASK A QUESTION TO- TO WITH THE-
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS. THAT
MAN I'M SURE THAT'S OKAY THAT'S
MISSED OUT FROM THE ACLU YES
PLEASE PROCEED SO- AND
OBVIOUSLY THE NUMBER OF THE
GROUPS THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION
GROUPS THAT I HAVE GREAT
ADMIRATION FOR SO- HEARING THAT
OPPOSITION AND LOOKING
CAREFULLY AT IT I TAKE IT VERY
VERY SERIOUSLY. MISTER OUT. USE
THE PHRASE AND THAT THIS WOULD
BRING THIS BILL WOULD BRING US
QUOTE BACK TO THE DRAWING BOARD.
AND AS I READ- THIS MEASURE
RICHEST. IT REQUIRES THAT A
NOTICE ABOUT HOW PARENTS CAN
INSPECT THAT THAT'S ALL I READ
THE BILL DOING IS GIVING
GUIDANCE ON HOUSE SO YOU CAN
CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO ME HOW BACK
TO THE DRAWING BOARD AND I KNOW
THIS IS A SENSITIVE TOPIC I AND
I APPRECIATE THAT A LOT OF
STRONG FEELINGS. COME OUT ON
THIS IN THIS AREA BUT HOW DOES
JUST NOT NOTIFYING PARENTS HOW
THEY CAN ACT INSPECTOR THROUGH.
THE MATERIAL. ROAD BACK TO THE
DRAWING BOARD. THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION- OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT BUILT
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE. MANY
DISTRICT TO ADOPT POLICIES NOT
JUST ABOUT THE ADOPTION OF
CURRICULA- BUT HOW THAT
CURRICULA IS MADE AVAILABLE
THAT WOULD REQUIRE- SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO PICK UP ANOTHER
VOTE- ONLINE- IT CAN TO SORT OF
NAVIGATE AND FIGURE OUT THE
DETAILS OF THIS NEW LANDSCAPE
AT THE THOUGHT OPPOSING FIRM
FOR POSTING MATERIAL ONLINE-
AND- ESPECIALLY BECAUSE MANY
MUCH OF THIS MATERIAL IS
COPYRIGHTED THAT WOULD REQUIRE
CAREFUL DISTRICT. CONSIDERATION
ON HOW TO NAVIGATE THE LEGAL
LIABILITIES OF THAT AND- YOU
KNOW IT WOULD REQUIRE FOR THE
EVENTUALLY TO REVISIT THAT
TOPIC- AND IN OUR EXPERIENCE.
ALTHOUGH MANY DISTRICT BURKE-
HAVE THE BOARD ADOPTED AND THAT
PROCESS WITH NEW AND SOME THAT
HAVE BEEN A CHALLENGE- DUE TO
THE AMOUNT OF OBJECTION THAT
DID NOT. TO INDIVIDUAL
CURRICULA ITSELF BUT TO THE
CONTENT THAT IS MANDATED BY BY
CHAYA LED BY A SMALL GROUP OF
FOLKS TO JACK TO SOME OF THAT.
I REQUIREMENTS ESPECIALLY
AROUND INCLUSIVITY AND I AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT BROADER CONCERN
BUT I WANT TO GO BACK TO WHAT
SPECIFICALLY IN THE BILL
MANAGER IF YOU ARE OUR
CONSULTANTS ARE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT. S. B. THIS IS THE
CRITERIA YES I WOULD I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO DO THAT- AND MAYBE THE
OPPOSITION IS A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSED. BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
ABOUT NEW CURRICULUM THIS IS
ABOUT THE CURRICULUM THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN ESTABLISHED AND
THIS BILL IS ABOUT ACCESS
MAKING SURE THE PARENTS HAVE
ACCESS. TO REVIEW THE
INFORMATION AUTHOR MY CORRECT.
THE SENATE BETTER OKAY VERY
GOOD. OKAY BECAUSE- AGAIN I'M
VERY SENSITIVE TO THE TOPIC
AND- THE OPINIONS THAT. PEOPLE
HAVE STRONG OPINIONS IN THIS
SPACE. BUT ONCE AGAIN AS I LOOK
AT THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE US
IT'S JUST SIMPLY TALKING ABOUT
ACCESS SO THAT'S WHERE I'M
STRUGGLING. AND CERTAINLY WOULD
WELCOME COST COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES SEE IF THEY'RE
SEEING IT DIFFERENTLY- BUT
APPRECIATE THAT CLARIFICATION.
THANK THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER
CENTER CORTESE. THE COMMISSION
SURE- JUST A- BUT THE QUESTION
OF FOR THE AUTHOR IF I MAY HAVE
BEEN JUST LET ME JUST SORT OF
SET THE STAGE FOR- IT FOR A
COUPLE REASONS ONE I DON'T WANT
TO BE IN A MISCONSTRUED AS JUST
BRING THIS UP FOR THE FIRST
TIME NOW I KNOW WE HAD A VERY
BRIEF BUT- I THINK CONCISE
CONVERSATION OR COMMUNICATION-
THE LAST TIME- WE- WE HEARD
THIS TOPIC IN. IL MY CONCERN
WAS. I'M ALL FOR TRANSPARENCY I
REALLY DO TAKE. OF THE AUTHOR-
ED HIS WORD IN TERMS OF THAT'S
THAT'S THE THRUST LISTS. WHAT'S
WRONGWITH TRANSPARENCY- MY
CONCERN IS SINGLING OUT ONE
SUBJECT- FOR GREATER
TRANSPARENCY WITHOUT. JUST
SAYING IF WE NEED TRANSPARENCY
LET'S DO IT ACROSS THE BOARD
AND I THINK. IT IT'S IT RAISES
CONCERNS AND SUSPICIONS- IN.
MAYBE NONE OF THAT IS WARRANTED
BUT- MY SENSE IS THAT NGUYEN.
IN THE ISM IN ON ONE PARTICULAR
SUBJECT PEOPLE SAY WHY THAT IN
IN- TO SEE LET ME LET ME. A
QUICK EXAMPLE AND THEN I'LL-
I'LL GET OFF THE FLOOR HERE
BUT- AS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
WE HAD LOTS OF ISSUES WERE I
ARGUED CURRICULUM BY CURRICULUM
WE SHOULD HAVE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY SOME OF THEM. WERE
BECAUSE OF PARTISAN SHIP
GOVERNMENT CLASSES PIPING IN A
TELEVISION CONTENT TO OUR
CLASSROOMS FOR EXAMPLE- I
ARGUED. YOU KNOW HOW DO WE KNOW
THAT WE'RE NOT GETTING PARTISAN
CONTENT ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
SHOULD WE HAVE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY- I CAN GIVE MORE
EXAMPLES I WON'T IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME- BUT- HE THAT
THAT'S MY CONCERN I DON'T WANT
TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO ADDRESS
IT. OF MY SENSE. IT HAD POINT
IS AS A RAISE THE QUESTION IS-
YOU KNOW THAT AS IT STANDS
RIGHT NOW- I WOULD THAT WOULD
NOT BE VOTING ON THIS BILL ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER BUT THAT
CERTIFICATE BEFORE I MAKE THE
FINAL DECISION I WANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU- AND I AND AGAIN. I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT I THINK-
TO PARAPHRASE MYSELF THE LAST
TIME AROUND- I WOULD I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT AND PERHAPS
EVEN CO AUTHOR BILL THAT. THAT
TAKES THIS LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY ACROSS THE BOARD
ALL EDUCATION SUBJECT MATTER
BECAUSE I THINK. THAT YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT THAT'S A GOOD
BECAUSE IN AND OF ITSELF. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
BEFORE I ASK YOU TO RESPOND US
SENATOR DOLLY. I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT THAT. THE OPPOSITE
ORIGINALLY TOLD ME THAT THEY
HAD A PROBLEM WITH THE BILL OR
HAVING IF THE EVERYTHING HAS TO
BE TRANSLATED. INTO THE
LANGUAGE OF CHOICE- WHICH I
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE IT CAN BE
TIME CONSUMING IT CAN BE AND
WILL BE. AND SO I ASK THE
AUTHOR TO TAKE THAT OUT
THINKING THAT THAT WOULD REMOVE
OPPOSITION. AND SO I WAS
SURPRISED TO HEAR THAT THEY ARE
STILL OPPOSED. THEN I RESPECT
THESE GROUPS GREATLY TO I DO A
LOT OF WORK WITH THEM AS WELL.
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
WAS SURPRISED THAT IT DIDN'T
REMOVE ANY OPPOSITION EITHER.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS BEFORE I GO TO
SENATOR DOLLY. SENATE ALI AND I
THINK YOU WERE GOING TO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS. YES SO FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
BECAUSE- SHE'S DILIGENTLY
WORKED WITH ME AND- TRYING TO
SHEPHERD THIS BILL THROUGH AND-
I WAS. I WAS A CO AUTHOR THIS
BILL BEFORE AND- THE AUTHOR-
DIDN'T ACCEPT THE MINUTES AND
DIDN'T WORK WITH A CHAIR AND I
THOUGHT IT WAS UNFORTUNATE I
THINK WE WOULD'VE BEEN A LOT
FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD. IF IT
BEFORE CO THAT HAPPENED I THINK
THIS IS A- VERY GOOD BILL. TO
ANSWER A CENTER CORTESE'S
QUESTION LOOK I. I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE ALL THE CURRICULUM PUT
UP THERE THIS IS A VERY.
SENSITIVE AREA OBVIOUSLY FOR-
YOU FEEL HER LOTS OF TESTIMONY
TODAY AND YOU KNOW. I'M A I'M
A- PARENT OF ELEVEN YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER. AND- I'M ENGAGE WITH
WITH HER EDUCATION ASSAM I KNOW
MOST ALL PARENTS ARE. AND YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT'S BEING TAUGHT
TO YOUR CHILDREN WHEN AND HAVE
WHAT IT WHAT THE ACTUAL
CURRICULUM IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK PARENTS SHOULD BE ENGAGE
AND I THINK THAT'S- WHY THIS.
PART OF THIS- CURRICULUM HAS
BEEN PUT OUT ITS PURPOSE I'VE
ASKED FOR TO BE PUT UP ON THE
INTERNET BASICALLY WE ARE NOT.
CHANGING ANY CURRICULUM THE
CURRICULUM THAT HAS BEEN
ADOPTED. IS ALL WE'RE ASKING
FOR IS TO JUST BE PUT UP ON THE
INTERNET SO PARENTS WHO CAN'T
GET TO THE SCHOOL OR DON'T HAVE
THE TIME TO GO IN AND DIG
THROUGH ALL THE MATERIAL. THAT
THE MATERIALS AVAILABLE. SO THE
QUESTION ABOUT COPYWRITING AS
WELL. IF IT'S CAUGHT HABITS IT
HAS BEEN PUBLISHED. PUBLISHED
IN ITS HEAD OKAY FOR THE SCHOOL
THERE SHOULDN'T BE ANY
COPYWRITING- PROBLEMS IT'S FREE
IT'S TO THAT YOUR TWITTER
TEACHER STUDENT. SO I DON'T I
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT ARGUMENT
OBVIOUSLY I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND. ALL THE
LAWS AROUND COPY WRITING BUT I
KNOW THAT. IF IT'S AVAILABLE TO
MY CHILD IN THE CLASSROOM IS
AVAILABLE TO ME. AND THE TO THE%
PUBLIC OF WHAT WE'RE TEACHING
OUR CHILDREN SO THAT. THE
ARGUMENT I DON'T UNDERSTAND WE
ARE NOT. I CAN I WANT TO STRESS
WE ARE NOT ASKING TO CHANGE
CURRICULUM ALL WE SIMPLY ARE
ASKING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION DO. IS PUT THAT
INFORMATION UP. I WANTED IT TO
BE TRANSLATED SO EVERYBODY
COULD. ACTUALLY ACCESS I THINK
THAT SOMETHING MAY WE SHOULD
WORK ON AS A LEGISLATURE FOR
ALL MATERIALS I THINK YOU KNOW
WE TALK ABOUT. IN CALIFORNIA
THE DIVERSE POPULATION IN
LANGUAGES WE HAVE YOUR AND THE
BARRIERS FOR THOSE FOLKS TO BE
ABLE TO GET THERE SO I WAS
HOPING THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
DO THAT THIS BILL. OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S GONNA DRIVE THE COST UP
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR SMALL.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BUT I'LL TAKE
WHAT I CAN GET IN THIS AREA I
TOOK THE AMENDMENTS FOR. FROM
THE COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS I HOPE
I ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION I
WOULD LOVE TO GO THERE BUT AT
THIS TIME I DON'T THINK WE CAN.
WE CAN GET THERE FOR A BROADER-
INFORMATION TO BE PUT UP BUT
FOR IN THIS AREA- AS I STATED
EARLIER IT'S BEEN VERY.
DIFFICULT FOR SOME PARENTS AND
IT'S A VERY SENSITIVE AREA- FOR
THOSE OF US WHO ARE. CHILDREN
WANTED MAKE SURE THAT WE KNOW
WHAT'S BEING TAUGHT WHEN IT'S
BEING TAUGHT AND YOU KNOW WE
CAN ENGAGE IN THAT AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT SO. WITH
THAT I WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I REALLY WANT TO JUST
STRESS- THE HELP FROM THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF AS
WELL. THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY WE
HAVE A MOTION. HELLO YES OKAY
SORRY ONE MOMENT. SENATE
MCGUIRE AND CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MANAGER. IN
PERSON FROM US I JUST WANNA SAY
HOW MUCH I RESPECT AND ENJOY
WORKING WITH CENTER DOLLY THAT
HE'S ONE OF THE BESTAND VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK. I THINK
MY ISSUE ON THIS SPECIFIC BILL
TO FULL NUMBER ONE AS A FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER MY WIFE IS
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL PRINCIPAL
MY GRANDFATHER WAS AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL PRINCIPAL ON
THE ISSUE OF SEX SAID. IF A
PARENT AND GUARDIAN WANTS TO BE
ABLE TO OPT OUT OF THOSE
CLASSES THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DO SO NOW. NUMBER TWO. IF THEY
WANT TO REVIEW THE MATERIAL.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO SO
NOW. IN NO OTHER SUBJECT. ARE
WE POSTING CURRICULUM ONLINE.
WE DON'T DO IT. SO WHY SINGLE
THIS ISSUE OUT IF THE ABILITY
FOR THE PARA THE GUARDIAN TO
ALREADY- TAKE THAT STUDENT OUT
OF THE CLASS. AND THEN SECONDLY
TO REVIEW THE MATERIAL WORKING
COLLABORATIVE LEE WITH THAT
DISTRICT IT'S THE PARENT OR THE
GUARDIAN TRIED. AGAIN TIS IS
NOTHING AGAINST THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE I GREATLY RESPECT
AUTHOR WE WORK TOGETHER ON MANY
ISSUES ARE NOT TO RESOURCES-
BUT YOU KNOW AGAIN I JUST I
HAVE. CONCERN ON THIS SPECIFIC
ISSUE BECAUSE CANDIDLY I JUST
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE EED IS.
FOR THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE AND NOT
EVERYTHING ELSE BECAUSE I DON'T
FIND THAT FOLKS ARE HAVING A
CHALLENGE REVIEWING THE
MATERIAL IF THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SEE IT OR OPT IN OR
STUDENTS HAVE. SIGNATURE THANK
YOU CENTER MCGUIRE CENTER
GLAZER. HELLO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- I JUST WANT TO.
PROVIDE A COUPLE CLARIFYING
POINTS BEFORE THE VOTE. ONE IS
THAT THIS IS NOT THE SAME BILL
THAT WE HEARD BY A DIFFERENT
AUTHOR IN A PREVIOUS YEAR IF.
THAT BILL- WOULD HAVE REQUIRED
A PARENTAL CONSENT AND OPT IN.
NUMBER- THAT FOR SEXUAL HEALTH
AND HIV PREVENTION EDUCATION
THAT THAT IS NOWHERE IN THIS
BILL. NUMBER IN THIS BILL AND
THIS BILL. HAS ELIMINATED THE
REQUIREMENT FOR TRANSLATION AS
WE HAVE JUST DISCUSSED THAT IS
ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE- AND SO ALL I'VE SEEN IN
THIS BILL- IS IT IS IT ISSUE OF
ACCESS AND IT'S A GENTLE- HOW-
THAT FOR ME- WHO IS A VERY-
PROTECTIVE OF LOCAL CONTROL THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN MAKE THESE
CHOICES NOW AND- AND EVEN WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT TRANSLATIONS
WILL. IF YOU HAVE MORE THAN 15%
OF YOUR POPULATION- LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH YOU SHOULD
BE THINKING ABOUT TRANSLATION.
THAT IS PART OF THAT
RESPONSIBILITY OF LEADERSHIP
AND I HOPE THAT THAT WOULD
HAPPEN. I'M GLAD THAT WE DON'T
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A STATE
MANDATE WHAT WE PLAYED YOU KNOW
WE TALK ABOUT THAT. A DIFFERENT
TOPIC AREAS AND IT'S A
SENSITIVE ONE BECAUSE WE WANT
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND WE WANT
TO- A CELEBRATE THE DIVERSITY
OF OUR GREAT STATE- BUT ALL
THAT THIS BILL SEEMS TO BE
DOING IT AND EVERYTHING THAT I
CAN SEE IS THIS ISSUE OF. OF
ACCESS OF HOUSE AND I'M A BIG
SUPPORTER TRANSPARENCY AND
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR FROM SAN
JOSE'S LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA.
AS WELL AND BEFORE TO PARTNER
WITH HIM ON ON OTHER APPLE
APPLE WAYS WE CAN DO THAT AND
HERE'S THE THING. IF WE HAD
ANOTHER SENSITIVE SUBJECT WE
TALK ABOUT SLIPPERY SLOPE. IF
WE HAD ANOTHER SENSITIVE
SUBJECT- AT THE END THESE
THINGS WILL COME AND GO AT IT
IN THE DECADES WELL THAT'S
SOMETHING FOR US TO TALK ABOUT
AND DISCUSS AND SEE WHETHER IT
SHOULD. APPLY TO THE SAME-
ADDITIONAL ELEMENTS OF HOW SO
THAT PARENTS CAN MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE ACCESS SO. GIVEN THE
LIMITATIONS IN THIS BILL. AND.
THE APPRECIATION TO THE CHAIR
AND THE AUTHOR HER FOR TRYING
TO FIND COMMON. AND A POLAR
POLITICAL AND- I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU CENTER GLAZER COUNTY GOT
THE FORM OF A MOTION THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE OKAY VERY GOOD
SENATOR BOB DOLE I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE. AGAIN I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE WAS SIMPLY
TRYING TO JUST BE TRANSPARENT-
AND- VERY HELPFUL I AGREE I'VE
WHAT I SAID WAS IF THE. IT IN A
DIFFERENT PLACE IN THOSE THOSE
THOSE WERE THESE AMENDMENTS
THAT I TOOK WAS TO WHAT- ART
TARGET CHAIR THAT SUGGESTED SO
THANK YOU AGAIN AND I
APPRECIATE IT I VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZERS MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB TWO SEVENTEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA HI LEYVA HI- CHEWABLE HI
BUT CHOI BOGUE BANKS FOR
TENNESSEE. OF VOTING FOR TODAY
NOT VOTING DALLI. DELI I GLAZER
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE NO
PAN. PAN NOT VOTING START
BILL'S FOR ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATOR NEWMAN
COME ON DOWN HE WILL BE
PRESENTING SB FOUR FOUR TO
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. YEAH
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MORNING. MORNING COULD
I HAVE BEEN PRESENTED TO
EDUCATION BEFORE IT'S
INTERESTING TO ONE MEMBER HAS
BEEN SINGLED OUT FOR TIME OUT
IN THE FRONT THERE. IF YOUR ARE
NOT. EARLY YOU GET TO SIT IN
THE PITT. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND CENTERS AYE I'M HERE
BEFORE YOU TO PRESENT AS BEFORE
FOR TO. A BILL THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE ABLE
TO SMOOTH THE TRANSITION FROM
AT LARGE ELECTIONS TO DISTRICT
BASED ELECTIONS. WITHOUT
ENCOURAGING INCURRING THE
PROSPECTIVE COSTS AND DELAYS
THE CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS
ACT LAWSUIT DURING THIS
PROCESS. SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
THE CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS
ACT IN TWO THOUSAND ONE TO
PROMOTE GREATER REPRESENTATION
AND EQUITY IN ELECTIONS. MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED OF CALIFORNIA
MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE SWITCHED FROM AT
LARGE ELECTIONS TO DISTRICT
BASED ELECTIONS. IN RECENT
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ENCOURAGED POLITICAL
SUBDIVISIONS SUCH AS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADOPT DISTRICT
BASED ELECTIONS WHAT
SIMPLIFYING THE PROCESS FOR
DOING SO. UNDER CURRENT LAW
EDUCATION CODE SECTION FIVE OH
ONE NINE ALLOWS COUNTY
COMMITTEES THAT OVERSEE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ORGANIZATION. TO
ESTABLISH TRUST ELECTIONS IN A
PROMPT AND INCLUSIVE PROCESS
UNFORTUNATELY FOR REASONS
HAVING TO DO WITH HOW VARIOUS
STATE STATUTES AND CODES
INTERSECT. THE CURRENT CODE
MAKES AN EXCEPTION FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GOVERNED BY A BOARD
OF EDUCATION PROVIDED FOR IN
THE CHARTER. OF THE CITY OR
COUNTY. SCHOOL DISTRICT FITTING
THIS DESCRIPTION ARE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED TO PUT ANY
ORDINANCE AND ESTABLISHING
TRUST YEAR ELECTIONS TO THE
ELECTORS OF THEIR DISTRICT
WHICH OFTEN RESULTS IN AN
OFFICIAL LECTION AND SOMETIMES
AN OFF CYCLE ELECTION AT
SUBSTANTIAL EXPENSE. TO THAT
LOCALITY IN PRACTICE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN BYPASS THIS
REQUIREMENT BUT SECURING A
WAIVER FROM THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. THIS EXTRA STEP
HOWEVER STILL ADDS TIME AND
ADDITIONAL COSTS TO THE
ADOPTION OF TRUST YEAR
ELECTIONS AND THIS DELAY HAS
RESULTED IN FURTHER AT LARGE
ELECTIONS THAT ARE IN VIOLATION
OF THE CVR RIGHT. THESE
UNNECESSARY COMPLEXITIES CAN
RESULT IN COSTLY LITIGATION AS
WELL AS SUBSEQUENT UNLAWFUL AT
LARGE ELECTIONS THAT PERPETUATE
THE DILUTION OF MINORITY VOTERS
IN VIOLATION OF EITHER THE
SPIRIT OR THE LETTER. OF THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT SB
FOUR FOUR TWO FIXES THIS
PROBLEM BY REQUIRING ORDINANCES
APPROVING A PROPOSAL TO
ESTABLISH DISTRICT. TRUSTEE
AREAS TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY UPON ADOPTION
WITHOUT THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
ACTION TO AFFIRM APPROVAL.
UNDER THE PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL THIS WOULD APPLY TO ALL
ALL ELECTION REGARDING MEMBERS
THAN ONE. TWENTY FIVE DAYS
FOLLOWING ADOPTION. NO THAT WAS
REMEMBER I TOOK AND EARLIER-
COMMITTEE THANKS TO THE CHAIR
OF THE LESS COMMITTEES WHO- WHO
IS A MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE.
WITH THESE CHANGES SB FOUR FOUR
TWO WILL STREAMLINE THE
TRANSITION PROCESS WHILE
ELIMINATING ADDITIONAL COSTS TO
TAXPAYERS RESULTING FROM
DELAYS. AND PROSPECTIVE
LITIGATION THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ENNIS HAD
NO OPPOSITION THUS FAR WITH ME
VIRTUALLY TODAY. IS MICHELLE
WERE SHOT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE WAIVER PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THIS MORNING. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN-
MISSILE WAR SHOW YOUR PREVIEW
YOU BEING ON THE LINE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
FOR SUPPORT. SEEING NONE OF THE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING NONE.
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE
UP ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
FOUR TWO. THE SHOW OF SUPPORT
FOR SB FOUR FOUR TWO PLEASE
PRESS STAR FOLLOWED ARE SKEWS
ME PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB.
FOUR FOUR TWO. AND AS. ADAM
SHAREIT SHOW NO PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU MR MODERATOR ALL
RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL. SO
WE'LL GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE FOR OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN
NONE MISS MODERATOR CAN YOU SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE QUEUE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO. TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF US BEFORE FORTY.
THANK YOU MEDICARE- TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB FOUR FOUR.
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE FILED BY. ZERO
MADAM CHAIR NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP. VERY GOOD THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OF THE
BILL THANK YOU CENTER PAM
SENATOR TROUBLED. I DO NOT EVEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORTH- I APPRECIATE THE
INTENT IN THE EFFORT ON ON ON
ON THIS BILL I AM CONCERNED-
WITH AREAS. OF MY DISTRICT ARE
IN MY AREA MY DISTRICT WHERE WE
HAVE VERY SMALL COMMUNITIES THE
MOUNTAIN AREAS JUST AN EXAMPLE-
WHERE IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
FIND. CANDIDATES TO RUN FOR
OFFICE AND ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT COMMUNITIES ARE
ABOUT THREE THOUSAND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND- TO FIND TO PUT
DISTRICTS IN THEM- I AM
CONCERNED THAT WE WOULD NOT
HAVE TO REPRESENTATION WE END
UP WITH VACANCIES AND IN SMALL.
COMMUNITIES. AND I'M AN
ADVOCATE FOR PRESENTED OF
GOVERNMENT. AT ALL COSTS BUT I
DO BELIEVE THAT WHEN IT COMES
TO- A STATE MANDATE. I THINK IN
IN BROWN'S OF. THIS TYPE OF
POLICY. IT IS BEST TO LET OUR
LOCAL. DISTRICTS IN OUR
AGENCIES DECIDE WHAT IS. OUT
WHAT WOULD WORK MOST
EFFICIENTLY TO HAVE GOVERNMENT-
IN PLAY IN IN THOSE TYPE OF
COMMUNITIES- AND SO I WOULD IN
WITH THIS TYPE OF NOTICE I
THINK AS YOU SAID. MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BUT CAN AND HAVE THE
ABILITY TO WOULD MOVE FORWARD
WITH DISTRICTS I KNOW WE DID-
BUT IN AREAS WHERE THE
POPULATION IS JUST VERY VERY
SMALL. AND NOT MANY PEOPLE ARE
WILLING TO ENGAGE IN CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT IT BECOMES VERY
DIFFICULT TO IMPLEMENT SO IN
PRINCIPLE I THINK IT'S A
WONDERFUL IDEA I THINK IN
PRACTICE IT WOULD MAKE IT VERY
VERY DIFFICULT FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO ENACT
THAT- OUR SMALLER COMMUNITIES
WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
ENACT SUCH A MEASURE- EITHER
FOR WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT.
ON THIS MEASURE BUT I DO. TRULY
DO APPRECIATE YOUR- AND YOUR
EFFORT IN A AND PER THIS. I
THANK YOU SENATOR CHOCOLATE LET
ME MAKE CLEAR THERE'S NOTHING
ABOUT THIS BILL THAT WOULD
COMPEL A DISTRICT TO SWITCH THE
BASIS FOR ITS ELECTIONS THIS
BILL SIMPLY COVERS A VERY
NARROW CARRIAGE FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHO WHO WHO'S WHO
RESIDE IN CITIES OR COUNTIES
THAT ARE PROVIDED FOR THAT ARE
GOVERNED BY A CHARTER- AND SO
ALL THIS BILL DOES IS IN THE
EVENT. THAT THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MEETING THOSE
CRITERIA SHIFT TO TRUSTEER
ELECTIONS IT MAKES IT EASIER
FOR THEM TO DO SO- AND SAVES
THEM THE COST OF AN ELECTION
AND THE COSTS OF RESTRICTIVE
LIMITATION TO BE VERY CLEAR WE
CAN HAVE DIFFERENCES OF OPINION
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA VOTING
RIGHTS ACT BUT IN THIS CASE
WE'RE SIMPLY TRYING TO. RENDER
CLARITY AND EFFICIENCY AROUND A
VERY NARROW CARRIAGE THIS WOULD
NOT APPLY TO BE A DUBBED AND IN
ALL LIKELIHOOD TO ANY THE
DISTRICT'S YOU JUST DESCRIBED.
OKAY SO THIS IS NOT A MANDATE
THAT YOU WOULD FORCE EVERY
EVERY ENTITY TO PURSUE SUCH A
MATTER ABSOLUTELY THIS IS ONLY
APPLIES TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO
ARE INTENT ON SHIFTING TO AT
LARGE TO FROM AT LARGE INTEREST
YEAR ELECTIONS BUT WHOSE
DISTRICTS ARE GOVERNED BY A
CHARTER FOR EITHER THE CITY OR
COUNTY- IN WHICH THEY SHOULD.
OKAY WELL I THINK THAT CHANGE
MY OPINION THE LADY SENATOR
MICHAEL. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
SENATOR DOLLY. SO I'M A LITTLE
TORN SO I UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
TRYING TO DO AND I KNOW THE
ISSUE THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DRESS BUT WHO IT IS STATES TEN
WHO CHOOSES THE VALERIE'S OF
THE OF THE DISTRICT AND I THINK
THAT IS WHERE- THIS IS HONING
IN ON SO CAN YOU TELL ME A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT HOW WHO
GETS TO CHOOSE THOSE. THOSE
DISTRICTS TYPICALLY THE BOARD
WOULD DO THAT- AND A LOT OF
THAT CENTER DOLLARS WOULD.
DEPEND ON HOW THAT PROCESS WAS
EITHER INITIATED- OR OR OR
UNDERTAKEN- BUT THERE'S NOTHING
ABOUT THE BILL THAT WOULD
CHANGE THAT PROCESS- THAT FOR
THE MOST PART IS A LOCAL
PROCESS AND DONE THE IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS. IN EVENT THE
SCHOOL THE DECIDE OF ITS OWN
VOLITION TO THAT OR IN RESPONSE
TO A DEMAND LETTER. OF YOU KNOW
FOR CALIFORNIA RIGHT TO RIGHTS
SIX SHOOT. BUT IT'S IN IN THAT
RESPECT IT'S NO DIFFERENT THAN
ANY OTHER DISTRICT. SO THERE'S
NO ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
GERRYMANDER THEN THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IT I
MEAN I'VE BEEN SOMEBODY WHO'S
BEEN ELECTED HIM INTO. COUPLE
SENSES IN TRYING TO DIVIDE UP.
SUPERVISORIAL DISTRICTS AND LET
ME TELL YOU SOMETHING THAT GETS
VERY POLITICAL ONE YOU CAN CARP
SOMEBODY OUT OR KEEP SOMEBODY
AND OR- AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
POINT I WANTED YOU TO DRESS OUT
I DO SHOULD ENTERTAIN TYPICALLY
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS IF IT
DISTRICT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
TRUST YEAR ELECTIONS. THEY
WOULD SURELY DID KNOW. THE
NEGOTIATOR WITHIN THE BOARD. TO
ENGAGE A DEMOGRAPHER WHO WOULD
THEN GUIDE THAT PROCESS YOU
WOULD LOOK AT THE DEMOGRAPHICS
WOULD LOOK AT THE PERSPECTIVE
LINES. AND THEN THERE'D BE. IS
BUT PROCESS FOR COMMUNITY INPUT.
YEAH YOU KNOW AND IN THE END
YOU TO YOUR- IT. BUT DO YOU
KNOW IF IT'S- THE SAME WAY AS-
MOST OTHER. LINE REDRAWING THE
STATE FOR THE MOST PART IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE FREE OF
GERRYMANDERING. SO THERE'S NO
SO THERE'S NO OPPORTUNITY I
MEAN ARE WE THINK ABOUT DISS.
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES INSIDE OF
A SCHOOL DISTRICT IT NEED TO BE
REPRESENTED ON THE ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT ALLOWING
THE ABILITY BILL TO
GERRYMANDER- SENATE I'VE HEARD.
SOMEBODY DOESN'T GET LEFT OUT
AND I KNOW THAT WE HAVE.
CHANGED THAT STATEWIDE WE WE'RE
GOING TO RIGHT NOW THERE'S JUST
THERE'S THE CENSUS IS AND WE
HAVE BEEN A BIT OF A BOARD TO
TEST OUT WHICH I THINK IS VERY
HEALTHY ACTUALLY. RICHARD SO
YOU KNOW THAT FOR THE MOST PART
IT'S EXTERNAL TO DO THIS BILL
IN ITS INTENT. SO YOU CAN THINK
ABOUT THIS BILL AS A WAY OF
ENABLING A PROCESS. THAT YOU
KNOW FOR THE OR THE TIMING. AB
YOU KNOW IT'S WHAT WE'RE
INTENDING TO DO IS MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IF AND WHEN I
DISTRICT DECIDES TO MAKE THIS
CHANGE- THAT THEY CAN DO SO.
WITHOUT HAVING OF A SPECIAL
ELECTION WHICH IS COSTLY. OR OR
WITHOUT BEING YOU KNOW PUTTING
THEMSELVES ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
A OF A PROSPECTIVE SEVERE A LOT
LAWSUIT. BUT BEYOND THAT YOU
KNOW THIS THIS MAKES IT DOES
NOT CONTEMPLATE HOW THOSE LINES
WOULD BE DRAWN IT WOULD BE NO
DIFFERENT. THAN ANY OTHER
JURISDICTION. INTO THE WAIVER-
OPPORTUNITIES SO THEY CAN WAY.
TILL THEY CAN HAVE A GENERAL
ELECTION WHICH- DRIVES THE COST
DOWN ISWHAT MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT CORRECT IT'S THE
OPPOSITE THAT THE WAIVER
OPPORTUNITY ALLOWS THEM TO NOT
HAVE AN ELECTION. AND JUST DO
THE DRAW THE DISTRICTS AN
INCORRECT BUT YOU KNOW BUT
BUILT TO THAT PROCESS IN SOME
WAY THAT. YOU KNOW ISSUES
AGREED UPON BY THE BY THE-
GOVERNING BODY- BUT THEY WON'T
HAVE TO THE END YOU KNOW TO THE
ELECTION. SO THAT'S A WHERE
LIES THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
JERRY MANNING IF THAT WAS A
THAT WHAT'S WHAT'S THAT. WHAT'S
REALLY YOU HAVE TO DRAW A LINE
SENATOR DOLLY AND SO. YOU KNOW
ONE MAN'S GERRYMANDERING
ANOTHER MAN'S LINES RIGHT SO WE
FACE THAT ISSUE EVERY TEN YEARS
RIGHT FOR YOU KNOW FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS- AND FOR THIS YOU
KNOW YOU'RE MAKING A CHANGE
BUT- TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT
CHANGE. IS THIS IS TO ENABLE
THE DECISION HAVING ALREADY
BEEN MADE. TO BE EXECUTED IN A
WAY THAT DOESN'T COST
ADDITIONAL MONEY OR UNTIL
ADDITIONAL TIME. BUT IT IT IT
DOESN'T YOU KNOW IT IT HAS NO
BEARING ON HOW THOSE LINES ARE
DRAWN. SO I UNDER I GET THE-
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE THE
RESOURCES BECAUSE IT IS VERY
EXPENSIVE TO DO SPECIAL LOOKS
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT I ALSO AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE YOU KNOW.
THE DRAWING THE LINES IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE IF A COMMUNITY
IS LEFT OUT- AND THERE'S NOT
SOME IT- ABILITY FOR FOLKS WHO
CAN PROTEST THOSE LINES- IN
THIS IS DONE BY THE BOARD THIS
IS GIVING THEM THAT ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT WITHOUT THAT
INPUT IF YOU'RE NOT LIMITED YOU
TO IT IT'S NOT GOING TO JUST BE
DONE BY THE BOARD IT'S GOING TO
BE DONE BY THE BOARD IN SOME
FASHION. THAT YOU KNOW THAT
MUTUALLY AGREED UPON BY THE
MEMBERS OF THAT BOARD BUT AGAIN
THIS WILL ENABLE THE BOARD TO
DO SO. WITHOUT INCURRING
ADDITIONAL TIME MORE EXPENSIVE
ELECTION SHOW- APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. BY THIS BILL NO
BEARING ON THAT LARGE. OF HOW
LINES WILL BE DRAWN ON WHETHER
NOT. YOU KNOW ONE PARTY WILL BE
ABLE TO THE OTHER IN THE
DRIVER'S LUNCH IT WILL NOT
CREATE ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR GERRYMANDERING. IT SIMPLY
MEANS THAT IF AND WHEN HE
DISTRICT MOVES TO AT LARGE
ELECTIONS UNDER THE CVR RIGHT.
IT WILL BE ALLOWED TO DO SO
WITHOUT IT BEING EXPENSIVE OR
PROSPECTIVELY. YOU KNOW BEING
LITIGATED. I'M I'LL I KNOW
WE'RE TRYING TO GO I'M A LITTLE
BIT CONCERNED ABOUT MAKING SURE
THEY GET SORT OF THE RIGHT WAYS
I'M ONLY OFF TODAY AND- DIG A
LITTLE DEEPER SO APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS OF THE- YOUR
QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD AND YES
CENTER CORTESE. YES- TO THE
AUTHOR CENTER NEWMAN AYE I
THINK IT'S- FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
IN AN EXCELLENT BILL BUT THEN I
COME FROM A COUNTY WHERE WE
HAVE ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT
HAS AN AT LARGE. SET OF
ELECTIONS SO WITH A HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN THOUSAND VOTERS IN
I'M SURE IF THERE WAS AN EASIER
WAY AND THEY WERE QUALIFIED
UNDER THIS PARTICULAR A
STATUTORY CHANGE- THERE'D BE A
LOT OF DISCUSSION ABOUT. A
POTENTIALLY CHANGING THAT TO
ONCE AND FOR ALL AND THUS
REDUCING THE COSTS ARE FOR
THINGS LIKE BALLOT STATEMENTS
AND OTHER THINGS THAT COME
ALONG- WHICH ARE REALLY
BARRIERS TO THE PEOPLE- YOU
KNOW GETTING THEMSELVES ON THE
BALLOT AND CONSOLES HEARD RIGHT
NOW IN. IN SOME OF THESE
DISTRICTS I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
COVERS ALL OF THAT OR THE OFTEN
WOULD SOLVE SOME OF THAT BUT I
THINK IT'S A HUGE STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION IN TERMS OF-
WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE- IT MAY
BE SOME. THAT'S BUILT ON
FURTHER IN THE FUTURE AND- I'D
BE. HAPPY TO COME ON AS A CO
AUTHOR IF. YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
THAT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
OBVIOUSLY THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT SENATORS ARE
GOING TO HAVE IS GOING TO THANK
YOU CENTER CORTESE ANY OTHER
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
TO HAVE EMOTIONAL EXCUSE BUT WE
HAVE A MOTION. SIR NUMERO JUDGE
CLOSE OF DEBT FREE SHAKE YOUR
THOUGHTFUL QUESTIONS APPRECIATE
SUPPORT THAT NICE RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR PAN META CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB FOUR FORTY TWO.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS SENATOR
LEYVA HI. HI OCHO VOTE HI
PATROL BOAT. HI COURTESY.
CURTIS III DALLI. DALLI NOT
VOTING GLAZER HI. GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE. PAN HI PAM HI WE'LL
LEAVE THAT BILL CALL. THANK YOU
SENATOR NEW HAVE A REST OF THE
DAY. ALL RIGHT OR AUTHORS
SENATORS. ICE HER. SHE WOULD BE
SPEAKERS. ITEMS SIX SB. SEVEN
TWENTY THREE- THE.
SEN RUBIO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. ONE GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO START OFF BY ACCEPTING ALL
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS TODAY I AM VERY PROUD
TO PRESENT SB SEVEN TWENTY
THREE WHICH WILL HELP CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND BUILT A
STUDENT TO TEACHER PIPELINE BY
ESTABLISHING THAT CALIFORNIA
LEADS. LEADERSHIP EXCELLENCE
ACADEMIC DIVERSITY SERVICE
LEARNING STATEWIDE TUTORING
PROGRAM FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE.
STUDENTS THIS BILL WILL ALSO
ALLOW COLLEGE STUDENTS TO EARN
CREDIT CDC WILL PROVIDE THE
GUIDELINES ON THE PROGRAM BUT
THE PROGRAM WILL BE FACILITATED
BY THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND HAVE THE OPTION
TO PARTICIPATE IF THEY CHOOSE
ONCE AGAIN THIS IS AN OPT IN
PROGRAM. NOT A MANDATE SINCE
I'VE ARRIVED IN THE LEGISLATURE
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT'S VERY
CLEAR EDUCATION IS MY PASSION
THEY WAS MY LIFE AND CONTINUES
TO BE IN SO MANY WAYS SO IS MY
PRIORITY TO FIGURE OUT A
PROGRAM THAT CAN HELP US. BRING
OUR STUDENTS UP TO SPEED AND
REALLY FOCUS ON THE CHALLENGES
THAT TEACHERS HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO PROVIDE TUTORING SERVICE
WITHIN THE SCHOOL DAY. THERE
ARE MANY STUDENTS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING ACADEMICALLY AND
NEED THAT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
AFTER HOURS WHICH AGAIN AS A
TEACHER I CAN ATTEST TO THE
FACT THAT BOB TUTORING IS NEVER
ENOUGH HOURS IN THE DAY TO HELP
THE STUDENTS AND SO I WAS A
REPEAT READING TEACHER FOR MANY
YEARS AND I. USED TO STRUGGLE
WITH THAT AND I USED TO ALWAYS
SAY IF I ONLY HAD JUST A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME BUT THERE WAS
NEVER ENOUGH TIME DURING THE
DAY. IN ADDITION TO THE
LEARNING LOSS IN GENERAL WE NOW
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE LEARNING
LOSS OF COVERAGE NINETEEN AND
HOW IT HAS AFFECTED AN ENTIRE
GENERATION OF STUDENTS AND-
AGAIN AS A TEACHER I CAN TELL
YOU THAT. THE GAP WILL ONLY
GROW EXPONENTIALLY IF WE DON'T
HAVE THE SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT
TEACHERS. NEED TO HELP THEM GET
THEIR- THIRTY. SUGGEST THAT AND
NUMBER OF TO ARE PER BELOW
GRADE LEVEL ALREADY. THE POLICY
ANALYSIS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION FOUND THAT STUDENTS
IN FOURTH TO TENTH GRADE
EXPERIENCE. LEARNING LOSS BOTH
IN MATH AND ENGLISH. AN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS WHAT ARE YOUR
GRADES EXPERIENCE THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF LEARNING LOSS IT'S
TRUE THAT IN ELEMENTARY AND
LOWER GRADES HE REALLY JUST
LEARN HOW TO READ. AND TO AND
THE BASICS LATER GREAT SPEECHES
HELP YOU EXPAND ON YOUR
KNOWLEDGE SO THE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL LEVEL IS WHERE WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON THIS PROGRAM. THAT
WILL HELP WITH THAT EIGHT
TWENTY SIXTEEN HARVARD STUDY
FOUND THAT ONE ON ONE TUTORING
WAS ESPECIALLY EFFECTIVE IN
INCREASING YOUR TREATMENT. OF
LOW PERFORMING STUDENTS OF ALL
ALL OTHER EFFORTS BUT AS A
SEVENTEEN YEAR VETERAN TEACHER
I CAN TELL YOU WITH CERTAINTY
WITHOUT THE STUDY THAT IT IS
CHIRLA. THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY
PROVIDES A CENTRALIZED
FRAMEWORK AND TOOL FOR THE
STATE TO USE BY PROVIDING
TUTORING SERVICES TO STUDENTS
WHO NEED IT THE MOST ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE CHILDREN. THAT COME
FROM ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
HOMES AND MOST OFTEN THEY WILL
NOT SEEK BILLS ARE TOURING
SERVICE OUTSIDE ON THEIR OWN.
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT THE
CERTIFICATION- IN THE QUALITIES
EXISTED PRIOR TO COLD AND THEY
HAVE ALWAYS EXISTED QUITE
FRANKLY HOWEVER NOW WITH THE
PANDEMIC THIS IS REALLY CLEAR
AND HAS BEEN HIGHLIGHTED AND SO
WE NEED TO REALLY FOCUS ON
TRYING TO PROVIDE THESE TYPES
OF SERVICES. THE WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY TO PURSUE A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS IS NOW WHEN WE HAVE
THE MAJORITY OF OUR STUDENTS
WEBSITE SUCH HIGH LEVEL OF
LEARNING LOSS. AND I WANT TO
ALSO BE VERY CLEAR FOR EVERYONE
HERE THAT THIS BILL IS A
SUPPLEMENTAL PROGRAM. IT IS
AFTER SCHOOL HOURS AND WILL NOT
TAKE AWAY ANY JOBS OR
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ANYONE
ALREADY IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM
IT'S MEANT TO SUPPLEMENT ONLY.
AND I WILL REPEAT IT TOO OFTEN
PROGRAM SO ANY SCHOOL DISTRICT
CAN OFTEN NOT UP TO- 'M SORRY
TUESDAY TO PARTICIPATE IF THEY
FEEL THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE
DISRUPTED SEVEN. SO AGAIN. NOT
ONLY WILL THIS BE CRITICAL TO-
CLOTHING A CHIEF GAS BUT A
WOULD ALSO SEE. THIS TO TEACHER
PIKE. WHEN NICE STORE THINKING
OF PRO I ALSO THOUGHT- BEING AT
A SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR AND HOW
I HAD A TEACHER WHO STARTED
TEACHING AND LYFT WITHIN THREE
MONTHS REALIZE HE JUST WASN'T
FOR HER AFTER INVESTING SO MUCH
TIME ENERGY MONEY AND
EDUCATION. THREE MONTHS IT'S
ALL IT TOOK FOR HER TO REALIZE
IT JUST WASN'T A CAREER PATH
SHE WANTED TO CONTINUE TO
PURSUE SOME OF THIS PROGRAM
REALLY GIVES TEACHERS AND THOSE
ASPIRING TEACHERS TEACHER
CANDIDATES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY WORK WITH STUDENTS AND
KIDS IN AND SEE IF THIS IS
SOMETHING THEY WANT TO CONTINUE
TO PURSUE. I HOPE THAT IT DOES
AND IT'S FAR IS A LOT MORE
TEACHERS AND A LOT MORE PEOPLE
TO COME INTO THE PROFESSION.
SOUGHT TODAY WITH ME I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE TO FIND ME AT
TWO WITNESSES ONE SHE IS RUDY
GAY YOU'LL SHE'S A TEACHER AND
SPEECH PATHOLOGIST AT DM
SETTLEMENT HE'S GOING BALLPARK
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I ALSO HAVE
WITH ME DONNA. PART TWO COBIT
TIME SORRY I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE I GOT HER NAME RIGHT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARENT
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION HERE TO
TESTIFY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU CENTER RUBIO WE WILL
GO TO YOUR LEAD SUPPORT. MS
YOU'LL PLEASE BEGIN. WHEN YOU
ARE READY YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
HELLO MADAM AND THEN OF THE CAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. MY
NAME IS REGINA YOU ALL AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SPEND A FEW
MOMENTS EXPRESSING SUPPORT FOR
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY THREE.
I COME TO YOU TODAY AS A PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER DESCENDED FROM
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHERS. WITH
TWENTY TWO YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
AND QUALITY EXPERTISE IN
LANGUAGE LEARNING IN THE BRAIN
LITERACY TEACHING PEDAGOGY AND
REAL WORLD CLASS EXPERIENCE. WE
IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
TEACHERS IN PARTICULAR ARE THE
UNSUNG AND OFTEN FORGOTTEN
HEROES OF THE ENDEMIC. WE HAVE
SHIFTED OUR PRACTICE NOT ONLY
ONCE. BUT CONTINUOUSLY DURING
THIS UNFORGETTABLE YEAR HE HAS
A LEAD OF THREE HUNDRED
NINETEEN THOUSAND FOR TEACHERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MADE THIS YEAR. BUT LET ME BE
FRANK WE DID EXCEPTIONAL AND
EXTRAORDINARY WORK WE DID THE
BEST WE COULD IN LESS THAN
IDEAL CIRCUMSTANCES. COMPROMISE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS CONSTANT
TECHNOLOGY ISSUES REAL AND
TANGIBLE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
HURDLES. ECONOMIC IN HOUSING
ISSUES AND THE NONSTOP
FINANCIAL CRISIS IN EDUCATION.
ALL SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED THE
LEARNING OF THE VAST MAJORITY
OF OUR STUDENTS HERE. THAT LONG
EVEN GREATER FOR STUDENTS FROM
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. I WILL NOT LIMON
THE QUITE A BLACK BROWN ENGLISH
LEARNERS FOR THE DIVERSITY IS
WHAT MAKES US HUMAN I WILL NOT
APOLOGIZE. IN THE COMPLEX AND
NORTH UNION ST THE IN THEIR
FIRST LANGUAGE I WILL HOWEVER
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SYSTEMIC AND
CONFOUNDING WAYS. IN WHICH THE
CURRENT SYSTEM OF EDUCATION
UNDERSERVED AND MARGINALIZED
IT. AND LET ME BE CLEAR IN BOTH
ANECDOTAL AND STATISTICAL WAYS
THIS FUNDAMENTAL. ARE ONLY
COMPOUNDED THE ISSUE. I'VE
HEARD IN THE MEDIA AND IN MY
OWN COMMUNITY THAT POLLUTION IS
JUST. RETURNED TO COURT.
TEACHERS ACROSS THE STATE
UNDERSTAND THIS IDEAS LONG AND
PROBABLY NINETY AND WE ARE
WAITING TO SEE WHAT OUR LOCAL
DISTRICT WHAT YOU FOR OUR
STUDENTS. I KNOW THAT SB SEVEN
TWENTY THREE IS A VERY REAL
STEP TOWARDS IN OUR DESIRE TO
MITIGATE THE LEARNING LOSSES WE
SEE IN OUR STUDENTS. AND A FEW
IMPORTANT ONE. THE BILL WILL
NOT ONLY PROVIDE RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT BUT IT WILL ALLOW
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
SCHOOL DISTRICT. THE. FREEDOM
TO STRUCTURE AND CONDUCT THE
PROBE GRAHAM IN THE WAY THAT
THE MEETS THE NEEDS OF THAT
PARTICULAR STUDENT. OKAY TO ME
ON THE CHEEK IS THAT WERE NOT
REAP. CURRENT PROGRAM BUT I DO
REPORT. DISTRICTS CAN. TO USE.
IT AT ALL STRUCTURE TO THE POOR
TEACHING THE CLASS NOT LAY MORE
FOR. ON OUR ALREADY. TEACHERS
THE BILL DE THIS BY RECRUITING
IN COMPTON STUDENTS. ARE
PLASTERED MINUTES PER SIDE.
PLEASE WRAP UP. AS WELL AS
TUTOR TIME OUTSIDE A CLASSROOM
TO SOME COST YOU LAST NIGHT I
TO ONE OF MY SPEC GRADE FIRST
YOUR CALL GREEN MIDDLEBURY
MA'AM YOU YOUR INTO YOUR OTHER
WITNESS TIME. AND PLAY BASEBALL
IT'S ALL HE TALKS ABOUT PLEASE
LET ME AND- HELP HIM ACHIEVE
HIS DREAM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO
THE NEXT WITNESS MS ARE TO
PREVENT YOU HAVE A MINUTE AND A
HALF. MADAM CHAIR I JUST GOT A
MESSAGE SHE GOT DISCONNECTED
BUT THEY'RE TRYING TO GET HER
BACK ON THE LINE PERFECT WE
WILL WE WILL GO TO HER. WHEN
SHE GETS BACK IN ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO WITNESSES IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WILL GREW TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEING NONE.
OPERATOR L. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWO THREE.
YES ARE YOU READY FOR ME. IT IS
DONE IS THAT YOU OFFER YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY GOOD MORNING CENTER
LEYVA AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
DONNA PARTY CONVENTION AND I AM
HERE ISN'T EDUCATION ACT. I
THINK WE LOST YOU. MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU SEE IF SHE
MOVES A MUTED HERSELF BECAUSE
WE DO SEE SHE STILL ON THE LINE.
OKAY MA'AM PLEASE ON MUTE. I DO
SO OR CONNECTED TO- REGARD TO
TOPIC PLEASE- ON MUTE IF YOU
CAN HEAR US. HI SILVERLINE
CONNECTED STILL AS WELL MADAM
CHAIR AND I ALSO SO THAT SHE IS
NOT MUTED ON OUR END OKAY LET'S
GO AHEAD AND GO TO ANY OTHER
CALLERS WHO ARE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTY THREE AND
IF WE GET HER BACK WE WILL GO
TO HER TESTIMONY. OKAY AGAIN TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR. THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FILED
BY ZERO AND WE WILL START TODAY
MADAM CHAIR BUT WITH ONLINE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHARTER FRIDAY NIGHT AFTER
NINTH GRADE STUDENTS BOARDING
CALIFORNIA AND A HIGHLY
SUPPORTERS THOUGH. THANK YOU.
WE WILL GO TO. AT THE MOMENT
WE'RE GATHERING LINES. MY SURE.
WOULD CRIPPLE POLLUTION MOVIES
REACHER LINES. ANNEX WILL GO TO
NINETY ONE GO AHEAD. WHY NINE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS DAVID MORE CARE. I
WOULD PARENTS FAMILY ENGAGE
COMMUNITY SERVICE- AND WE'RE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION AND WE
SUPPORT SB. SEVEN TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BURKE GOOD
MORNING MY NAME RICARDO BOB
GOOD PUBLIC PARKLAND COLLEGE
STUDENT NIGHTS SUPPORT BILL OUT
SEVEN TO THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AS A REMINDER TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR LINE SB. SEVEN TO
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ALAN ON THE POPULAR COUNCIL
MEMBER FROM THE CITY OF BALDWIN
PARK AND EMPLOYEE OF THE PUBLIC
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
HOW DO YOU SUPPORT THEMSELVES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANNA LET
YOU KNOW- THAT SPEAKER DID ARE
THAT WITNESSED DROP WELL I WILL
LET YOU KNOW SHE REJOINED OKAY
OKAY SOUNDS GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR OUR MODERATOR OKAY
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OPPOSITION
WE DID NOT HAVE ANY LEGAL WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE MORE LIKE TO TAKE
THOSE I APOLOGIZE YES WE DO
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR. REAL
GOOD THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
pCAMPAIGN AND I AM TRYING TO
BECOME A TEACHER SACRAMENTO
AREA- IN A TIMELY SUPPORT IN A
RADIO BEACON TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. A LINE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAMES STEPHANIE GARCIA- I AM
THE PARENT OF A FOURTH GRADER
AND A COMMUNITY SERVICES
SPECIALIST FOR A LOCAL ON
GARBAGE COULD DISTRICTS MAY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL- AS
A PARENT AND AS A COMMUNITY
LEADER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A COUPLE
CUTE OUT. WHAT OPERATORS.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS LAURA SANTOS I'M A
COLLEGE BOARD MEMBER AT MOUNT
SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE AND I JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR IT SB SEVEN TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LAURA. N. LINE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JEFF GORDON ON
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF CHARLES
UNIFIED LOCATED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COULD BE THE
CALIFORNIA- I JUST WANNA LET
YOU KNOW THAT WE ARE FULLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE SB SEVEN TWENTY
THREE AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS ADDITIONAL RESOURCE THAT ALL
OF US ARE GOING TO NEED OUR
COMING YEARS THANK YOU SIR THE
MORNING LOGIC. OPERATOR PLEASE
GO TO THE NEXT CALLER. JUST
NAME AND ALL SUPPORT PLEASE.
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT. AND AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS CUED UP MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATE. HOPE TO HEAR SOMEONE
I COULD SPEAK AND IT'S JUST ON
OUR TICKET YEAH I SPEAK IN
FAVOR HELLO WE GOT YOUR BACK
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING TENER LEYVA AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. AS I SAID MY NAME IS
DON OR TO GIVE. I'M HERE AS AN
EDUCATION ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN STRONG
SUPPORTER SB SEVEN TWENTY
THREE. I'M A FORMER TEACHER OF
NEARLY THIRTY YEARS AND A
FORMER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER DAN
HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
PGA AS A PARENT AND A
GRANDPARENT. THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA SUPPORTS LEGISLATION
THAT CAN IMPROVE THE ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT FOR ALL STUDENTS
AND ELIMINATE THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP. WE BELIEVE IT IS IMPORTANT
TO PROVIDE ALL STUDENTS WITH
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN. AND
WHEN NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTION STRATEGIES. AND
REMEDIATION PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
ACADEMIC SUCCESS. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A TUTORING PROGRAM
THAT WILL BE A TREMENDOUS BOON
TO STUDENTS K. TWELVE WHO HAVE
BEEN HIGHLY AFFECTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. PARENTS ARE WORRIED.
MS ARE STRUGGLING. ARE
SCRAMBLING TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO
THE LEARNING LOSSES WHICH HAVE
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
DETRIMENT TO MANY OF OUR
CHILDREN. THE VISUAL TUTORING
HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE WAY TO HELP PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT SUCCEEDING
ACADEMICALLY. INDIVIDUAL
TUTORING THAT ONE TO ONE TOUCH
WITH A TUTOR CAN REACH OUT TO
AN INDIVIDUAL STUDENT AND FIND
OUT WHAT IS THE ISSUE WHY IS A
STUDENT STRUGGLING WHAT KIND OF
SPECIFIC HELP IS NECESSARY IT'S
LIKE A MAGIC TOUCH. I KNOW WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO MEET WITH STUDENTS
INDIVIDUALLY I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS OFTEN
WHEN I WAS TEACHING. IT'S LIKE
OPENING A WINDOW AND SEEING THE
HORIZON FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME- NOW I SEE WHY YOU ARE
BEHIND NOW I UNDERSTAND YOUR
PROBLEM LET'S TRY THIS. AND IT
WORKS IT GIVES STRUGGLING
STUDENTS A CHANCE TO GROW IN
WAYS THEY DIDN'T REALIZE WERE
POSSIBLE. WE A STUDENT IS
WANTED TO. A TUTOR DISK THIS.
PROBLEM A CHILD IS HAVING
UNDERSTANDING SOMETHING TO
CONVENTICLES LANDED IN A WAY
THAT THE CHILD FROM GRASS. YES
INDIVIDUAL TUTORING IS
ESSENTIAL ALSO I REALLY
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE WIDE
RANGE OF POSSIBLE SHOOTERS
MENTIONED IN THIS BILL.
STUDENTS YES RETIRED TEACHERS
LIKE ME GONZALEZ DONIGER PASTOR
TEN MINUTES. CAN YOU WRAP UP
PLEASE- INCLUSION WE URGE YOU
TO PASS THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
AS OF THIS MORNING WE HAD NO
LEAD OPPOSITION BUT WE DID GET
SOME LATE OPPOSITION. SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO SANDRA. BAY AREA
I BELIEVE SHE'S ON THE LINE.
YES MORNING MADAM CHAIR GOOD
MORNING. CENTER BORRERO ON
BEHALF OF CSEA AND WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AND I APOLOGIZE TO THE
COMMITTEE AND OF THE AUTHOR FOR
LATE OPPOSITION WERE OPPOSED
BECAUSE THIS TYPE OF TUTORING
SHOULD BE PERFORMED BY TEACHERS
OR PARA EDUCATORS A RECENT
SURVEY OF DOZENS OF STUDIES
FROM MIT DETERMINES TUTORING
PROGRAMS USING TEACHERS AND
EDUCATORS ARE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT WAY TO
IMPROVE STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
THIS IS WHY AB EIGHTY SIX
ALLOCATED FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR
TRIGGERING THE PHYSICALLY
PERFORMED BY CERTIFICATED AND
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES TO DRESS
CODE BUT NINETEEN LEARNING WHAT
COLLEGE STUDENTS WITH
POTENTIALLY NO TEACHING
EXPERIENCE SHOULD NOT PROVIDE
THIS TYPE OF INDIVIDUALIZED
SUPPORT ALSO FEATURES WOULD
ESSENTIALLY BE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND NOT EMPLOYEES
OF THE DISTRICT. COPA'S
REQUESTING AN AMENDMENT TO
SPECIFY THAT THE TUTORS ARE
EITHER CERTIFICATED OR
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
EMPLOYEES TO ENSURE THE BEST.
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY. I WILL GO ROOM
FOR TWO OF THEIR ANY. SEEING
NONE WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NONE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN TWO
THREE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AGAIN TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB
SEVEN TO THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE WILL
START WITH Y. NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NINETY THREE
WE'RE OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
JENNY MARQUESSATE ON WITH
PARENTS FAMILIES ENGAGEMENT AND
COMMUNITY SERVICE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN
TWENTY THREE YEAH. WE ARE
TAKING OPPOSITION BUT THANK YOU
FOR REGISTERING YOUR SUPPORT.
AND AS MADAM CHAIR SAID TO SHOW
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR
SB. SEVEN TWO THREE. M. ADAM
SURE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS ARE
QUEUING UP. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR ALL RIGHT WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR PAM. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- SIR RUBIO I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS BILL I DID HAVE
A COUPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
DRESS- IN ANALYSIS THEY DID.
RAISE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT- THE
FUNDING FROM AB EIGHTY SIX AND
THIS PROPOSAL- SO I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY THIS PARTICULAR BILL
IS NOT SEEKING TO TAP INTO THE
FUNDING THAT WE FROM THE- THAT
WE RE ALLOCATED- THROUGH OUR
BELIEF EARLY BUDGET ACTIONS. SO
YOU CAN SPEAK TO THAT AND HOW
ALSO- YOUR BILL IS CORRECT
COORDINATE WITH WHAT WAS AN
EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX IN TERMS OF
THE- OTHER TUTORING PROGRAM SO
I KNOW THAT YOU SAID THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO BUT- JUST. HOW THE
TO MY INTERFACE OR NOT AND JUST
AND ALSO CLARITY ON THE SOURCE
OF FUNDING FOR THIS PARTICULAR
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR
PAT FOR- FOR ASKING THAT
QUESTION AND SO I KNOW THAT AB
AT SIX ALLOCATED A LOT OF
FUNDING FOR SPECIFICALLY FOR
TUTORING EXTENDED LEARNING TIME
SUMMER SCHOOL AND THE LIKES AND
SO THIS BILL DOES NOT INTENT TO
TOUCH ANY OF THAT FUNDING. BY
AND I'VE STRESSED AND I WILL
RESTRUCTURED- MY HOPE IS THAT
WE COULD SUPPLEMENT BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT THE NEED IS GOING TO
BE GREAT. AND I UNDERSTAND THE
FEAR OF SOME OF THE OPPOSITION
AND WHAT THEY CALLED AND I YOU
KNOW I HEARD THAT TEACHERS AND
CERTIFICATED ARE BEST QUALIFIED
TO PROVIDE THESE TUTORING
SERVICES ABSOLUTELY AGREE A
100% BUT I CAN TELL YOU AS A
TEACHER. WHO TAUGHT IN THE
SCHOOLS AT DISTRICT AND SYSTEM-
WE CAN NEVER HAPPEN THAT. WE
CAN NEVER HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE
TRYING TO HELP BUT YOU KNOW
AFTER HOURS AFTER SCHOOL AND
THE CHALLENGE WE'RE HAVING TO
IS THAT WE HAVE. YOU KNOW- WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TEACHERS THAT
STILL WANT TO TAKE ON TUTORING
AFTER HOURS I MEAN THAT'S- AS A
TEACHER I CAN TELL YOU THAT WAS
ALWAYS A CHALLENGE I MEAN
YOU'RE EXHAUSTED YOU'RE TIRED
YOU'RE TRYING TO PRODUCE. OFTEN
TELL YOU'RE TRYING OUT TUTOR.
BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE BEFORE
SCHOOL DURING RECESS LUNCH WE
DON'T HAVE RESEARCH WE CAN HAVE
LUNCH. THAT WAS MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE I'M NOT SPEAKING TO
SPEAKING FOR ME. BECAUSE THAT'S
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO GRAB
OPPORTUNITIES TEND TO HELP
THESE KIDS. BUT THE HOURS
DURING THE DAY ARE NEVER AND
NOT STILL I DO I GUESS THAT THE
INTENTION OF THIS BILL IS NOT
TO TOUCH THAT FINDING OUT ALL.
THE INTENTION OF THIS BILL IS
NOT TO. DISPLACE ANY TEACHER
ANY CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE ANYBODY
THAT'S ALREADY WORKING WITHIN
THE SCHOOL SYSTEM. AND WHEN YOU
SAY HOW IS THIS GOING TO WORK-
AT BOTH PROGRAMS. BOB THAT IS
WHY ISN'T OFTEN PROGRAM. IF A
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS DOING FINE
AND READY IS UP I'M YOU KNOW
GETTING ALL THE TUTORING THE
ME. THEY DON'T HAVE TO OPT IN.
BUT I THINK IT'S UP TO EACH
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
DECIDE TO WE NEED THE HELP OR
NOT AND JUST HAVING THIS THERE
AS A TOOL THAT THEY CAN USE.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT IT'S JUST
THAT JUST ANOTHER TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX IT'S NOT A MANDATE. AS
FAR AS THE FUNDING WE ARE STILL
EXPLORING THE FUNDING SOURCE SO
IT'S- OPINION APPROPRIATION BUT
THIS WILL NOT BE THE SOURCE OF
FUNDING WE INTEND TO USE. AT
ALL SUCH AS WANT TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR. THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE
THAT SO- YEAH I THINK THAT-
THE- NIGHT AIR G. TO TALK TO
THE OPPOSITION WHICH I KNOW
CAME IN LATER IN THE EVENING OF
MADE IT OUT SO- IN ALL FAIRNESS
TO YOU- THAT THAT. JOB DATE
AND- SHARE WITH YOU THEIR
CONCERNS EARLIER ON- CERTAINLY
I KNOW THAT YOU'RE SIMPLY AS A
TEACHER WHO KNOWS THE FIELD
WELL AND KNOWS THE IMPORTANCE
OF CYRUS SCHOOL EMPLOYEES I'M
SURE TO YOU'LL REACH OUT TO
THEM NOW THAT THEY'VE EXPRESSED
HER CONCERNS AND- HOPEFULLY CAN
WORK THOSE OUT CERTAINLY I
WILL. I'LL BE VOTING FOR THE
BILL TODAY I WANT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT BUT I ALSO.
HOPE THAT- AND I NOTE THAT- WE
CAN SORT OUT SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT THEY'VE RAISED- DO AGAIN
APPRECIATE THAT ESPECIALLY WITH
BECAUSE OF IT AND THE
TREMENDOUS DEMANDS- THAT. WE'RE
PLACING DOWN BOTH TEACHERS AND
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES THAT- THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY. TO ALSO GET
THEM SOME OF. THE L. TEMPER
INSTITUTIONAL- AND ALSO. CAN
YOU PERSUADE SOME . TO ENTER
INTO. FIELD WELL THROUGH THE
THROUGH. UNDER X. THAT MY BE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
WELL SO. I PREFER WHEN YOU TRY
TO DO THINK SO MUCH CENTER. DR
PAN AM ONE DISCUSS ADDRESS THAT
SOUGHT TO BE. THAT'S THE HONEST
TRUTH I HEARD ABOUT THE
OPPOSITE THIS MORNING AT AND UP
TO NOW. I DON'T KNOW THEY WERE
OPPOSE SO I WOULD I HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS PRIOR TO COMING
TO YOU. BUT FOR THOSE LISTENING
I WANT THEM TO KNOW I'M ON
THEIR SIDE I'M ON THEIR TEAM
I'M TRYING TO MAKE THEIR JOBS.
EASIER AND DIE AND JUST TRYING
AGAIN SUPPLEMENT AND I WILL
WORK WITH THEM ABSOLUTELY WE
CAN. DEFINITELY. CLARIFY SOME
OF THAT THE CONCERNS. EIGHT
SENATOR GLAZERS YOUR QUESTION
CALM. PLEASE WELL I THINK THE
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE KIDS- SHE
CONTINUE TO GUIDE ALL THAT WE
DO HERE- AT FOCUSED ON THEIR
SITUATION- SENATOR I SO
APPRECIATE YOUR BACKGROUND YOUR
TEACHING EXPERIENCE AND THE
INSIGHTS THAT YOU BRING TO OUR
WORK HERE AND- CERTAINLY- IT'S
REFLECTED IN THE BILL THAT YOU
BROUGHT BEFORE US TODAY- THAT
IS THE ISSUE LEARNING LOSS IT'S
PROFOUNDLY- WORRISOME- AT THE
DEEPEST LEVEL OF MY SOUL. ALL
THAT WE HAVE DONE TO SURVIVE
THIS PANDEMIC WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SCARS AND THERE ARE
GOING TO BE CONTINUING
CHALLENGES. AHEAD AT ALL
ASPECTS OF OUR LIFE IT'S
CERTAINLY FOR OUR KIDS I'D
CERTAINLY FOR- THE THAT THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY HAVE FACED
SO YOUR BILL IS MORE TIMELY
THAN I COULD EVER EVER BE IN
THIS SPACE HOW DO WE HELP THEM
CATCH UP. AND HOWDO WE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU KNOW THE PERFECT
HOW WE LOVE TO SEE EVERYTHING
REALLY DONE CAN GET IN THE WAY
OF ACTUALLY JUST TRYING TO FIND
WAYS TO LIFT YOUR KIDS UP AND
HELP IN ANY WAY WE CAN HELP OUR
SCHOOL COMMUNITY- IN ANYWAY
THEY CAN. THAT YOUR BILL IS
RESPONSIVE TO- INDIVIDUAL
CHOICES THAT THERE MAY BE OUT
THERE WITH THE OPT IN
PROVISION- I THINK THE ONLY
THING THAT I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER IS THAT THE STATE
ALICE'S NOTES THAT WE HAVE IN
SOME INCREDIBLE PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN OUR STATE- AND IT
WOULD SEEM LIKE IT WOULD BE
FAIR TO GIVE THEM THE SAME
ELIGIBILITY. HOW YOUR BILL TO
ADVANCE TO BE SIGNED AND
FUNDING TO BE AVAILABLE TO OPT
IT AS WELL AND ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER THAT AND I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. AND UNDER
CLOSE TONIGHT- TO SPEAK TO THAT
WE WILL BE INCLUDING CHARTER.
SCHOOLS AS WELL THAT WAS. AB IN
OVERSIGHT SO ON IN THE NEXT.
WILL THE BILL TO INCLUDE THE AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
CORTE. THANK YOU MA'AM SURE- I
APPRECIATED THE TO THE
APPROPRIATE YOUR- EXCHANGE WITH
SENATOR PAN OF. REGARDING. THE
AB EIGHTY SIX DOLLARS AND- THE
INTERFACE OF THE PROGRAMS THE-
IT JUST IT STRUCK ME AND I
ACTUALLY- JUST GOING OVER PAGE
SIX OF THE ANALYSIS SIX OF
SEVEN IT SAYS ON THE TOP OF MY-
PACKET HERE- HE THEY WERE SORT
OF MORE QUESTIONS THAN ANSWERS
REYES AROUND THOSE ISSUES SO I
APPRECIATE YOU- RESPOND TO THAT
IS AND ALSO. INDICATING THAT
IT'S AN AFTER SCHOOL WHAT KIND
OF A PROGRAM. I TRIED TO INTEND
TO- CASSON I BOOKED IT FOR YOUR
BILL TODAY BUT I DO ALSO THINK
BERMAN ESPECIALLY AFTER. AND IF
YOU'RE SERVING AS AS ASCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER AND BRINGING ON-
MENTORING PROGRAMS MENTORING
PROGRAMS FROM THE YOU KNOW
BALLING CBO'S IN THE COMMUNITY-
OTHER KINDS OF VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS THAT IT OF COURSE GETS
A LITTLE BIT TRICKY WHERE EVERY
OF CLUB COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE- TO MAKE
SURE THAT. YOU KNOW SOMETIMES.
A DISCUSSION TAKES PLACE
SOMETIMES IT CAN BE JUST AS
SIMPLE MEET AND CONFER AND
SOMETIMES THERE MAY BE
SOMETHING IN THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT ALREADY
THAT THAT REQUIRES A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN THAT- IN A JUST
WANTED TO FLAG THAT. BECAUSE I
THINK. YOU KNOW THE WORST THING
THAT COULD HAPPEN IS TO HAVE A
PROGRAM THAT. INTENDS TO
AUGMENT LIKE YOU SAY SORT OF
WITH HUMAN RESOURCES- IN A TIME
OF NEED AND THEN HAVE IT
RUNNING INTO- ALL KINDS OF
CONFLICT IN IN THE DISTRICTS
HIMSELF UP THIRTY DISTRICTS IN.
A BASICALLY IN MY SENATE
DISTRICT IN EACH ONE OF THEM
HAS. A SEPARATE- SOMETIMES THE
SAME UNITS BUT AS YOU ARE QUITE
AWARE A SEPARATE UNITS THAT.
ALL HAVE THEIR OWN SEPARATE
AGREEMENTS THE COUNTY OFFICE
CAN'T REALLY CONTROL ANY OF
THAT PER SE- SO ANYTHING YOU
CAN DO IN THE BILL GOING
FORWARD TO. ARTICULATE PROCESS
THEY'RE ON THE UP ON THE
OPPORTUNITY THINK IT HAPPENS
AUTOMATICALLY IF THEY OPT IN
THEN THEY SHOULD UNDERSTAND.
THAT IF THEY HAVE AGREEMENTS IN
PLACE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO CONTEND WITH THOSE- BUT
I SUSPECT THAT- PUT IN A LITTLE
BIT MORE BUT DIRECTION
ARTICULATION IN THE BILL IF
YOU'RE SO WILLING- YOU KNOW
BETWEEN NOW AND- WHEN IT SIGNED
INTO LAW- WOULD WOULD HELP. FOR
SMOOTHER LANDING- YOU KNOW WHEN
THE STAR TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
ARE OFTEN AT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT LEVEL AGAIN AND I'M
JUST I'M JUST SHARING. THE
CONCERN I THINK IT'S SORT
PERHAPS SIMILAR TO. A CENTER
PEONS CONCERN PLEASE BUT WITH
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT HE
ASKED- AND EVEN- EVEN IN THE
MOST- YOU KNOW SORT OF STRAIGHT
FORWARD OBVIOUS SENSE AGAIN
GOING BACK TO PAGE SIX IF
YOU'RE USING IT AT ALL TO STAND
UP THE PROGRAM- AB EIGHTY SIX
DOLLARS OR PROP NINETY EIGHT
DOLLARS FOR THAT MATTER AS WE
ALL KNOW TYPICALLY THERE'S
GOING TO BE SOME SORT OF- SOME
SORT OF A GO SHE ATION THAT
TAKES PLACE IN IN. IN ANY
GUARDRAILS OR GUIDANCE THAT THE
BILL COULD GIVE THIS TO HOW.
HOW AND WHEN THAT SHOULD TAKE
PLACE AT THE BECAUSE- IS
IMPORTANT YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
IT BEING VERY SUCCESSFUL SO-
THANK YOU- APPRECIATE. WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS A SAID A
SOMEBODY WHO'S- MY WIFE AND I
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
MENTORING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BROUGHT IN. MUCH IN THE SAME
WAY YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS- IN MY
HOMETOWN SO I APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH RICHARD WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND AGAIN I WILL CAST MY VOTE
TODAY. HOPE THAT YOU'LL-
CONSIDER SOME OF THE COMMENTS
MADE TODAY THANK YOU. BIG
CENTER CORTESE CENTER DOLLY.
THE MANAGER I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU I'M WHOLE HEART AGAIN
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY AND YOU
KNOW. THERE'S A THERE'S BEEN
MANY PIECES OF LEGISLATION-
THAT ARE MOVING THROUGH TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
YOU KNOW I THINK WE'RE
FORTUNATE IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE WE HAVE REVENUE
THERE'S- I WELL I MET WITH
THEM. DID AS SOON WITH LIKE
SEVERAL TWENTY SCHOOL DISTRICT
THE PRINCIPLES AND
SUPERINTENDENTS- IN MY DISTRICT
AND- THAT THERE'S RESOURCES
AVAILABLE WE NEED WE NEED TO
GET- THOUGH. SOME HELP FOR THE
WE DON'T KNOW THE IMPACTS OF
WHAT CODE IS DONE AND- WE WON'T
REALLY SEE THAT UNTIL MAYBE
YEARS LATER BUT RIGHT NOW I
THINK IS THE TIME TO STRIKE I
THINK THIS. IS A TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX THAT WILL HELP THOSE
STUDENTS- PROBABLY NOT THIS
YEAR BUT HOPEFULLY IN THE FALL
WILL BE ABLE TO DO IT SO I
SUPPORT YOUR BILL I KNOW
THERE'S SOME. OBVIOUSLY THE
DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS AND HOW
IT REALLY GETS LAID OUT I KNOW
YOU'LL YOU'LL BE PASSIONATE
ABOUT WORKING OUT SO I'M IS FOR
YOUR BILL TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING IT ON THE
FLOOR SOON HOPEFULLY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
GLAZERS CENTER REVIEW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S COMMENTS AND TO-
MISTER CORTESE'S- COMMENTS
ABSOLUTELY WE WANT THIS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL SO WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO BRING. ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER AND
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
BECAUSE I WANT TO PUT SOMETHING
FORWARD THAT'S REALLY GOING TO
HELP NOT TAKE AWAY FROM WHAT WE
ALREADY HAVE. AND YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF THE CHARM I BELIEVE
THAT MR GLAZER STATED IT AND SO
DID MISTER DALI. BOB WE DON'T
KNOW HOW OLD IT IS GONNA AFFECT
OUR CHILDREN IN THE FUTURE BUT
I CAN TELLYOU I TODD AFTER
NINE ELEVEN. AND WE CAN SEE THE
TRAUMA IT WASN'T JUST ON THE
EDUCATION ACADEMIC SIDE BUT THE
TRAUMA TO OUR CHILDREN AT LAST
YEAR'S AND YOU KNOW FORTUNATELY
WE KNEW WHICH KIDS HAVE LIVED
THROUGH NINE ELEVEN BECAUSE YOU
CAN SEE A LITTLE BIT OF THAT
AND- AND SO WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS JUST GOING TO BE SOMETHING
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH IN TERMS OF COMING OUT A
COUPLE OF IT AND- AND THAT
CHILDREN JUST. FEELING
CONFIDENT IN BEING ABLE TO
FOCUS ON THE ACADEMICS NOT
WHAT'S HAPPENING AROUND THE
WORLD BUT I REALLY WANT TO
BRING ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER MAKE SURE THAT. YOU
KNOW THEIR VOICES ARE HEARD AND
THAT WE PUT FORWARD A PROGRAM
THAT REALLY DOES HELP IN THE
END IT'S ALL ABOUT HER CHILDREN
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T EVEN BEHIND AND WITHOUT
MANAGER I ASKED FOR. CAN I BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER GLAZER MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE NUMBER SIX SB SEVEN
TWENTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND.
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATE SINCE LEYVA. I
LIVE ON OCHO ABOVE. I WHICH
WILL BOTH ON CORTEZ. CALL TO
THE AYE DALY. DELI I. GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE. PAN HI. AND I.
BELIEVE BILL LONG CALL BUT IT
DOES. ENOUGH OF SEAT OUT THANK
YOU SAID RUBIO. NEXT IS GOING
TO BE SENT ROTH. GOING TO BE
PRESENTING OUR LAST TWO BILLS
OF THE DAY FILE ITEM SEVEN AND
EIGHT. I WILL THROW FIVE. SEVEN
SB SEVEN. THAT IN THE. WRONG
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE PLEASE
BEGIN. SACRAMENTO RICHARD
COLLEAGUES- THANK YOU TO YOUR
AND YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL. I WILL BE. GLADLY
ACCEPTING ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS
AS OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS
THANK YOU SIR. YOU KNOW IN
CALIFORNIA THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
OUR- OF THE ATTORNEYS APPEARING
IN CASES THAT OUR COURT ROOMS
AND THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE
JUDGES WHO WERE HEARING THOSE
CASES ARE OFTEN. QUITE
DIFFERENT THAN THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF THOSE APPEARING IN FRONT OF
THEM. FRANKLY THERE'S A
DIVERSITY GAP IN THIS BILL WILL
HELP CLOSE THE DIVERSITY GAP
THAT CONTINUES TO PERSIST. THIS
LACK OF DIVERSITY SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTS EQUITABLE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE AND
ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE
REPRESENTATION OR AT LEAST THE
PERCEPTION. OF EQUITABLE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE AND
ACCESS THROUGHOUT OUR JUDICIAL
SYSTEM HOWEVER THERE IS AN
EXISTING AND SUCCESSFUL.
STATEWIDE INITIATIVE OPERATING
THROUGHOUT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND OUR
OTHER. SCHOOLS AND UNIVERSITIES
THAT ADDRESSES THIS DIVERSITY
ISSUE BY BUILDING A DIVERSE
EDUCATIONAL PIPELINE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL TO LAW SCHOOL. CALLED
THE LAW. PATHWAYS PROGRAM ASMAN
AND SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVEN
ZERO WILL HELP EXPAND THIS
MODEL TYPE PLAN AND CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE STUDENT
PARTICIPATION IN PATHWAYS TO
THE LAW PROFESSION. SO WHILE
THE BILL SPEAKS TO IMPROVING
DIVERSITY IN THE LAW PROFESSION
IN OUR COURT ROOMS IN THE
ANALYSIS IN THE BILL ITSELF
COVERS THAT. AND THE BILL
CERTAINLY WILL DO THAT. AT ITS
CORE THIS BILL ADVANCES A
PROGRAM THAT FRANKLY REACHES
DOWN INTO OUR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND SCHOOLS WITHIN
THOSE COMMUNITIES TO PICK THE
CURIOSITY OF STUDENTS. WITH
REGARD TO A CAREER IN THE LAW
AND TO PROVIDE A COORDINATED
PATHWAY FOR THOSE STUDENTS FROM
HIGH SCHOOLS TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS
TO LAW SCHOOL AND ULTIMATELY TO
A GOOD PAYING JOB. AND A CAREER
IN THE LAW. FOR SOME. THIS IS
BEEN LIFE CHANGING AND WITH
HELP FROM THIS BILL IT CAN BE
SO FOR MANY MANY MORE BUT I'M
SURE I HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TODAY ASIA THOMPSON A
STUDENT AT UCLA SCHOOL OF LAW.
TEN TWENTY N<c.cyan> THE PRESIDENT</c>
OF FOOTHILL COLLEGE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL VERY GOOD
THANK YOU A SENATOR ROTH AYE WE
WILL START WITH MS THOMPSON AND
I'M GOING TO MISS MS WIND YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING ASPEN IN THE CALIFORNIA
PASSED AWAY HE'S MEAN THAT
INVESTMENT AND THOUSANDS MORE
STORIES LIKE MINE. I WOULD NOT
BE WHERE I AM TODAY WITHOUT
THIS PROGRAM I WAS INTRODUCED
TO THIS PROGRAM IN THE TENTH
GRADE BECAUSE OF THE CURRICULUM
I COOK EVERY YEAR. ATTORNEY BY
MAC I DECIDE TO BE HOME LATER
BUT MENTAL MAKING A DIFFERENCE
IN MY COMMUNITY. I THANK
CONNECTION AND THEN RESTARTED
MAIN PERTINENT TO MY PROGRESS
AND- I WOULD NOT HAVE GONE INTO
COLLEGE WITHOUT THIS PROGRAM.
IT WAS THE CONNECTION I HD IN
ITS PROGRAM I WROTE MY LETTERS
OF RECOMMENDATION HELPED ME
PICK MY CLASSES ONE OF MY
MAJOR. IT WAS THESE CONNECTIONS
I WOULD CHECK UP ON THE EVERY
FEW MONTHS TO ENSURE THAT I WAS
ON THE RIGHT TRACK YOU GET A
LAW SCHOOL. YOU SEE THE PATHWAY
DID NOT EXIST WHEN I WAS IN
COLLEGE SO I HAD TO PUT ALL THE
PIECES TOGETHER MYSELF. AND IT
WAS THE RESOURCES I HAD FOR THE
PROGRAM WHICH I RELIED ON
HEAVILY THAT ENSURING MY
SUCCESS. I WOULD NOT HAVE MADE
IT TO LAW SCHOOL WITHOUT THIS
PROGRAM IT WAS THE SAME
CONNECTIONS I WROTE MY LETTERS
OF RECOMMENDATION CRAPPIE FROM
MY ENTRANCE INTERVIEWS. THAT
GAVE ME TIPS AND TRICKS BEFORE
THE SCHOOL YEAR STARTED ABOUT
HOW TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND CHECK
ON YOU ALONG THE WAY.
SACRAMENTO I HAD AS A SENIOR IN
HIGH SCHOOL JUDGE JUDY JOHNSON
GAVE ME MY FIRST SUMMER JOB
AFTER MY FIRST YEAR OF LAW
SCHOOL WORKING AT HER CHAMBERS.
THE FACT THAT I HAD FAMILIARITY
WITH THE JUDGMENT ABLE TO WORK
WITH HER HAS SET ME APART FROM
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES. I OWE
THAT TO THE PATHWAY PROGRAM.
AND INVESTMENT IN THIS PROGRAM
ALSO MEANS THAT INVESTMENT THAT
COMES FULL CIRCLE I WILL BE A
MENTOR FOR THIS PROGRAM AFTER
TAKING THE BAR IN JULY I'VE
ALREADY RECRUITED MY LAW
SCHOOL. FRIENDS AND I TELL
EVERY ATTORNEY I COME ACROSS
ABOUT THE PROGRAM AND THEY HAVE
ALWAYS EXPRESSED HOW THEY ACT
SEARCH FOR PROGRAM JUST LIKE
THIS ONE TO GET INVOLVED. IN
CONCLUSION THAT NEEDS TO GROW
BECAUSE WITHOUT IT STORIES LIKE
MINE WILL NOT EXTEND AND
INVESTMENT AND THIS PROGRAM
MEANS THAT IN BACK IN THE LEGAL
FIELD ALCOHOL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS THOMPSON MUGHAM. IS
WHEN. THANK YOU. SENATOR CORKER
MORNING MATT SHARED. MEMBERS
CRITICAL. IS ONE OF THE TWO
EIGHT COMMITTEE COLLEGE IN THE
PAST. I AM ALSO AN INTERN CRIED.
YOU CAN. ALL WHERE PATIENT.
WILL BE GLAD. USED OF MY THE
TEN LOCAL THAT HAVE SIGNED AN
AMMO YOU TO BE PART OF THE
PATHWAY. THE LEGISLATURE MADE
UP. TO COME EQUAL. TO JUSTICE.
THERE IS NO. STRIVE INTO
DIVERSIFY THE LEGAL OKAY. IT'S
A LOT PROBABLY WOULD CREATED
THAT EXACT PURPOSE. TEN AND
AFTER AMERICAN STUDENT FROM
RICH. EVIDENCE WHY WE SHOULD
HAVE TRICKSTER PATHWAY I'M
QUITE TO LAW SCHOOL SHE AND
THEN OTHERS. ABOUT IS THE
REASON WHY NEED THAT. THAT THIS
WIDE PIPELINE CAN GROW INTO
REACH AND IMPASSE. NETWORK IT'S
SOMETHING JUDGE MENTOR IS ONE
OF MORE THAN THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS JUDGES AND
LAWYERS. IN CALLING FROM TIMES
EVEN PRO BONO SUPPORT FROM THE
LIVE. ACTION TO THAT PATH IS
THAT. EXPO THE PROBLEM PROVIDE
EARLY. TO THE- ESPECIALLY FOR
WHO HAVE NEVER THAT COULD OF
THE- PROVIDING INSTANCE
VARICELLA. OF WALKING THAT THE
AMERICAN CARS AND SEE. WE HAVE
A STATE EVENT INCLUDES THE
FARMER BY EXAM. TEACHING ACTUAL
EXAM WATCH. STUDENTS WILL
DEBATE WHETHER. BACK WEEK WHILE
HEARING FROM TRADE. ARE DIVERSE.
NEWMAN MOMENT THE BILL WOULD
COME SUPPORT CONTENT PROGRAM
BAND. LEVERAGING BIG EQUITY. OF
DUAL AND- THE BILL ALSO WOULD
HELP THE STATE BY DATA SYSTEM
EVEN WITH THE WE DO HAVE WE
KNOW THERE IS INCREDIBLE. SIX
RAN FOR EXAMPLE FRESNO CITY
COLLEGE OF THE ONE HUNDRED FIVE
STUDENTS ACTIVELY PURSUING THE
LAW PASSED AWAY THIS YEAR. 85%
OF THE STUDENTS ARE STUDENTS OF
COLOR 64% ARLACCHI MAC. IT'S
PETER HIGH SCHOOL BOARD HIGH
SCHOOL HAD MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS IN THE LOG
CABIN THE- TWENTY TWO HIGH
SCHOOL TWENTY EIGHT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. TEN UNDERGRADUATES
AND TEN LAW SCHOOL WITH THE
VILLAGE OF VOLUNTEER JUDGES AND
LAWYERS. THIS CALL PATHWAY IS
THE FIRST OF ITS KIND IN THE
COUNTRY. FOR EDUCATIONAL
SECTORS WITHIN SINGLE FOCUS TO
DIVERSIFY THE LEGAL PROFESSION.
THAT IS ONE OF THE LEAST
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE PROFESSIONS
IN THE COUNTRY. THE PROBABLY
ALL HELPING TO MANAGE DIRECTOR
PLEASE. AND ENCOURAGES STUDENTS
TO BE MORE CIVICALLY ENGAGED.
ALTOGETHER LEAD TO A SOCIETY
THAT. IS MORE FAIR. THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
WE WILL GO TO FORTY- THREE FOR
ANY SUPPORT. SEEING THAT GO TO
ROOM FIVE. SCENERY MISS
MODERATOR DO HAVE A ON THE WITH
A TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SAID. SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN SO ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FIVE BY ZERO AT THIS TO. ONE
FILE BY USING. AND WE WILL GO
TO MY NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINETY EIGHT YOUR OPEN. WELL
MOVING ALONG WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE MOMENT. ONE OH FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING THIS
IS ANGIE MARTINEZ THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WITH A CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
SEVEN ZERO. SIX AND ROCK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I CAN SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN SEVEN
ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AN LINE ONE OH FIVE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CARE
MEMBERS MAX TERRY ON THE OFF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR THERE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL WILL GO TO ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE SEEN NONE GOOD ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEN NONE MISTER
MODERATOR WE'VE COME UP ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO. SB SEVEN
SEVENTY. SPEAKING OPPOSITION TO
SB SEVEN SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND I'M
SURE NOBODY'S KILLING UP THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SENATOR PAN AND THEN CENTER
CORTESE. THANK YOU CENTER ROTH-
IT IS A PHYSICIAN EVEN I WILL
ADMIT THAT WE NEED TO HAVE MORE
AND MORE DIVERSE SET A LAWYER
SAYS SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND-
ACTUALLY WOULD MOVE TO BUILD
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER PANCETTA
CORTESE. YES SIR THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND IT'S SENATE
ROTH GREAT BILL I HAD. MY IN MY
SENATEDISTRICT- THIRDS
STUDENTS TAKING FINALS AS WE
SPEAK THAT WOULD HAVE NEVER
BEEN IN THAT POSITION- HEAD OF
THIS PATHWAY PROGRAM NOT
EXISTED IN THE FIRST PLACE AND-
OBVIOUSLY TAKES MONEY TO EXPAND
IT GOOD. I'M EXTREMELY
SUPPORTIVE AND- WOULD LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. IF YOU'RE
WILLING- THANK YOU AGAIN AND
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS CENTER
GLAZER. SO I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES
IN THANKING THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
RECOGNIZING THAT COMPLAINING
ABOUT DIVERSITY IS ONE THING
BUT DOING SOMETHING ABOUT IT IS
SOMETHING ELSE. AND THIS TYPE
OF TARGETED PROGRAM CAN REALLY.
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN A
STUDENT'S LIFE I WANT TO. ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK GOODNESS
TOPS INDIA YOU LEAD WITNESS WHO
SPOKE EARLIER- FOR HER
PERSISTENCE AND DETERMINATION-
NOT JUST TO ACCOMPLISH ALL THAT
SHE HAS AND BE. ADMITTED INTO A
GREAT LAW SCHOOL UCLA- BUT ALSO
FOR HER WILLINGNESS TO- TO PAY
BACK PAY IT FORWARD- IN A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS AND THE WORK
THAT SHE'S PLANNING TO DO-
GOING FORWARD GO BRUINS AB. AB
IS FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZER SENATOR JOE BUG.
CENTER OUT THEY REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS BILL- VERY MUCH
AND FOR THE REASONS THAT HAVE
BEEN SHARED BY OUR COLLEAGUES
IN BY THE STATEMENT THAT YOU
MADE EARLIER. I JUST HAD A
QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO
ACCESSIBILITY- ON BEHALF OF
PARTICIPATION FOR THE HIGH
SCHOOLS AND JUNIOR COLLEGES.
HOW WERE THEY SELECTED AND
WOULD IT BE OPEN TO OTHER
SCHOOLS BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS PROGRAM. ABSOLUTELY
OPEN TO OTHER SCHOOLS
OBVIOUSLY. OF THE INDIVIDUALS
INVOLVED IN THIS AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO REALLY IT'S BEEN
HANDLED BY VOLUNTEERS AND
OTHERS ON A PRO BONO BASIS
PRIMARILY WHICH IS WHY THE
FOUNDATION WAS ORIGINALLY
INVOLVED WE'RE TRYING TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE THIS.
INSTITUTIONALIZE ISN'T BUILT ON
THE PROGRAM TO DEVELOP CAPACITY
THE SCHOOLS ARE SELECTED BY
LOOKING AT DEMOGRAPHICS TO TRY
TO PICK THOSE SCHOOLS WHERE WE
CAN ACTUALLY REACH. IN THOSE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
STUDENTS WHO MAY NEVER KNOW
ABOUT PROGRAMS LIKE THIS WHO
MAY NEVER HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO GAIN THE EDUCATION TO OBTAIN
THE TYPE OF GOOD PAYING JOBS
AND CAREERS SUCH AS CAREERS IN
THE LAW THEIR OTHER PATHWAY
PROGRAMS AS WELL THIS ONE. JUST
HAS TO DO PARTICULARLY WITH THE
LAW BUT WE LOOK TO SCHOOLS
WERE- IN DEMOGRAPHICALLY
CHALLENGED COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEIR- UNDERSERVED STUDENTS TO
TRY. TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO GIVE
THEM OPTIONS- SUCH AS THE- ARE.
BY WITNESS. BUT TODAY THAT
ANSWER THE QUESTION. I GUESS.
MOST AND I KNOW THIS WOULD HAVE
BEEN A PROACTIVE- REACH FROM
THE FOUNDATION IS THERE A
POSSIBILITY THAT SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN REACH COULD
ACCESS OR COULD REACH OUT IN IN
CONSIDERATION OF BEING A
PARTICIPANT ABSOLUTELY AND THIS
IS NOT A FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE A
PATHWAY PROGRAM. IN WESTERN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY RIGHT NOW AND
I WANT I CAN SPEAK TO IS THE
WAY THOSE SCHOOLS WERE SELECTED
AND THEY DID LOOK FOR SCHOOLS
AND- IN THE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES TO TRY TO REACH
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT MAY
NEVER HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY THERE
IS ABSOLUTELY. AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ADD SCHOOLS AND EXPAND IN
FACT THAT'S THE PURPOSE. IT
ONCE WE GET TO THE FISCAL
COMMITTEE FOR ABLE TO GET THE
MONEY THAT'S THE PURPOSE FOR
THE MONEY IS TO BUILD CAPACITY.
TO TAKE THIS TO OTHER SCHOOLS
TO OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
OTHER. HIGH SCHOOLS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND CONNECT
THEM WITH ADDITIONAL FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
TO EXPAND THE PROGRAMS THERE
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO DO. IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY TO THE EXTENT
THERE'S NOT ONE THERE AND I'M
NOT CERTAIN- AND OTHER COUNTIES
AROUND THE STATE. PERFECT THANK
YOU SO MUCH BETTER OFF LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING ABOUT
THANK YOU THINK THANK YOU
CENTER CHOI BOGUE SEEING NO
FURTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN SENATE ROTH WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. AMEND
CHURCHES THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE
KIND REMARKS AND APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY AS
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR RON. THE BILL FOR
MEMBERS AND PAN MADAM SECRETARY
CHEESY MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE NUMBERS. SB
SEVEN SEVENTY. THE MOTION IS
THE PATH OF THE BENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA. BY LEVI BOETTCHER ABODE
HI THE CHOI BOGUE ACRIDIDAE.
CORTEZ THE AYE DELI. DELI AYE
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
PANTAI AND I. THE BILL HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT BUT WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR SENATOR
MCGUIRE SENATE ROTH YOU HAVE
OUR FINAL BILL OF THE DAY ITEM
EIGHT SB EIGHT OH TWO PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR COLLEAGUES OF.
RESHOOT YOUR PARTNERSHIP DOING
DURING A RECENT SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT HEARING FOR THE
BUREAU OF PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. THIS BILL
IS THE SUNSET BILL FOR THE
BUREAU AND STEMS FROM OUR
CONTINUING WORK AND I EMPHASIZE
THE WORD CONTINUING THIS YEAR
TO COLLECTIVELY DETERMINE THE
BEST PATH FORWARD TO ENSURE
STUDENT SUCCESS AND QUALITY
EDUCATION WHILE RECOGNIZING THE
NEED FOR APPROPRIATE
TRANSPARENT REGULATION OF THE
PROGRAMS. WHICH OFFER TRAINING
AND EDUCATION TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS IN THIS FIELD I'M
ACCEPTING ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
APPRECIATE THE COLLABORATION OF
MR MIRRORS ON YOUR STAFF IN
BRINGING THESE IMPORTANT
CHANGES TO FRUITION- I LOOK FOR
YOU AS YOU KNOW THIS IS A
CONTINUING WORK IN PROGRESS I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT
WORK WITH ALL OF YOU THE BUREAU
THE SCHOOLS. AND STUDENTS ON
THIS NECESSARY BILL TO
GUARANTEE THAT PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY ACT PREVENTS
PREDATORY PRACTICES AND
PROMOTES THE ADVANCEMENT OF
STUDENTS WHO ATTEND BUREAU
APPROVED INSTITUTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE POINT TIME I'D RISK
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ROCKS I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE TO LEAVE
SUPPORT WASN'T WITNESSES MS
COCHRAN AND MS WERE FREE AND WE
WILL GO TO MISS COCHRAN PLEASE
PROCEED TO EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES. SHE DID NOT OKAY WHAT
ABOUT OUR LEASE OVER FRUITY.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING. THE
BUREAU HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY WE
WILL GO TO THOSE IN SUPPORT AND
FORTY TWO OR THREE SEEING NONE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY CENA MISTER
MODERATOR WILL PLEASE YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO IS
IN SUPPORT OF. S. B. EIGHT OH
TWO. ARE YOU READY FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT MANAGER YES PLEASE KEEP
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT OH TWO.
I AM SORRY I IT KIND OF CLICKED
OUT FOR A MINUTE I THOUGHT
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID THANK YOU
NOT A PROBLEM AGAIN. AND AGAIN
TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR S. B.
EIGHT OH TO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND AS A REMINDER PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
FOR S. B. EIGHT ZERO TWO. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE ZERO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MATT I'M SURE THIS IS MATH BACK
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY SCHOOLS ARE CAPS-
JUST WANNA START BY SAYING WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE RE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE BUREAU. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
INSTITUTIONS AND SCHOOLS THAT
ARE DAY AND STUDENTS AND
INSTITUTIONS TO HAVE A STRONG
CONSISTENT AND EFFICIENT
BUREAU. WE CLEARLY KNOW THIS
BILL IS GOING TO PASS WHICH WE
SUPPORT- BUT WE DO WANT TO
RAISE JUST A COUPLE OF QUICK
CONCERNS. THE ISSUE WITH
POTENTIAL HARM. PUTTING THAT IN
THE ENFORCEMENT SECTION- THAT
THAT THE VAGUE TERM AN OPEN
ENDED THAT RAISES CONCERNS FOR
OUR MEMBERS. CERTAINLY WITH DUE
PROCESS. I'M AS THE BUREAU CAN
REVOKE ABORTION THE LIFE- I'M
THIS IT WILL BE PROPER. HARM
THAT THAT DOES RAISE CONCERN.
BUT WE ALSO LIKE TO SEE THE
ADDITION OF SOME GUARD RAILS
AND SOME ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE
DEALING WITH STRESS. AND MAKING
IT CLEAR WHEN AND HOW THE
BUREAU CAN'T RAISE OR DECREASE
THE STRESS. EARLIER THIS YEAR
WE HAD A SITUATION WHERE IT
ENDED UP BEING A RETROACTIVE
SHE- FOR THE STUDENTS AND I
THINK WE CAN AVOID THAT. AND
THEN FINALLY AS WE ALL KNOW THE
BUREAU HAS. OFFERED SOME
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES WE
APPRECIATE THOSE ARE NOT IN
THIS BILL- BUT I DO EXPECT
DIALOGUE ON THAT GOING FORWARD.
AND NOW WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING TOGETHER WITH EVERYBODY
AS. THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GEAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL NOW GO TO WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION- I'M SORRY MISS
MODERATE TO HAVE ANYONE ELSE
ONLINE I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
NOT AT THIS TIME GREAT THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW GO TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WHICH THERE IS NONE.
FORTY TWO OH THREE SAYING NO
ONE WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NO ONE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU COMMIT ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN.
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT ZERO
TWO. TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR
SB EIGHT ZERO TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. I'M
BEGINNING TO SHOW YOUR
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT ZERO TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOBODY IS KILLING UP
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE CENTER
GLAZER AND SENATOR PAN.
BARCLAYS FOR SEAFOOD OR GLAZER
AT CENTER ROCK THANK YOU FIVE
FOR ADVANCING THIS IMPORTANT
BILL OBVIOUSLY IT'S SOMETHING
WE WANT TO SEE I WANT TO SEE
CONTINUED. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN YOUR JOINT
HEARING- THE OTHER WEEK UP
THERE ARE SOME THORNY ISSUES IN
THE SPACE I KNOW YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO TRYING TO FIGURE
THEM OUT WORK THEM OUT WITH
YOUR- VERY CAPABLE STAFF AND I
KNOW THIS BILL WILL HAVE A
DIFFERENT. CONTENT IN IT WHEN
IT COMES BACK TO THE SENATE- IN
A FEW MONTHS. NOW BUT WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND HAPPY TO
MOVE TO BUILD THE CORPORATE
TIME. THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZERS
CENTERPOINT. THANK YOU AND I
KNOW THAT SINCE AT A GLITTERING
WITH THE BILL JUST THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON THAT AND THEN
AND THEN YOUR LEADERSHIP AS
CHAIR OF UP THE ANTE IN. COURT
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
ON FIXING THESE ISSUES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
PAN THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER GLAZER I SEE NO MORE
DISCUSSION. SENATE ROTH WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
RESPECTFULLY AS FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK THANK. THANK YOU SIR- THE
BILL HAS BEEN MEMBERS CENTER
GLAZER MA'AM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE NUMBER
EIGHT SB EIGHT OH TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
LEYVA HI THEY'VE AYE OTOBO. I
HAVE A TROUBLED BY CORTESE.
CORTEZ THE AYE DELI. DELI I'D
GLAZERS. GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE PAN. AM FLIGHT.
BILLS OUT THANK YOU SENATOR
ROTH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS AS YOU LEAVING THOSE
HERE VOTED I JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU THIS IS OUR FINAL
HEARING FOR RIGHT NOW. GREAT
WORK BY EVERYONE SO I WILL WE
WILL SEE YOU BACK WHEN WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY BILLS. ALL RIGHT MADAM
CONSULTANT. LET'S OPEN THE ROLE
ON. FILE I. TO THE FIRM TO
PLEASE YES- CONSENT CONSENT YES
AND MCGUIRE NOT VOTE ON THAT-
PLEASE CALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
CAN- CONSENT CAN CHAIR VOTING A
VICE CHAIR VOTE ON MCGUIRE
ACQUIRE I'M SEVENTH THAT IS OUT
SEVEN. SEVEN SEVEN ZERO KILL
FILE ITEM THREE SB FOUR FOUR TO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE NUMBER THREE SB FOUR FOUR
TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR
VOTING ALL HIGH MCGUIRE ACQUIRE
THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO NO
EXCUSE ME. SIX SIX ZERO SIX
VALLEY VOTED NOT VOTED VERY
GOOD THANK YOU MADAM CONSULTANT
THAT BILLS OUT SIX ZERO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOR THAT IS
CONCERNED WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER. SIX SB SEVEN
TO THREE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS PHONE NUMBER SIX SB
SEVEN TWENTY THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING I VICE TRIGGERING
AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN
THE BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVING
TO FILE ITEM SEVEN S. B. SEVEN
SEVENTY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
SB SEVEN SEVENTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
BILLS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WANT TO THANK YOU
AND INCLUDES YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR INFORMATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA AND THE COMMITTEE.
ON EDUCATION IS ADJOURNED.